Schalke strauchelt Düsseldorf im Aufschwung. Die 2. Liga bleibt weiterhin spannend. Und wir wollen darüber sprechen mit Thorsten Wiese von Gebrabbel Rot-Weiß und Michael Fischer vom Vierter Flachpass und den Nürnberger Nachrichten. Und jetzt geht's los. Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Langeheil fliegt vorbei, und der Ball ist im Tor! Und Augsburg ist oben! Rossi zu Kurzabwehr, lang genug für Willi Landgraf! Wagner, Martin Wagner!
Und das an's Turno. Markus Kort aus dem Gewühl.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Ja, willkommen zurück zur Ligatour zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Mein Name ist Eva-Lotta Bohle. Ich freue mich, dass ich euch auch in diesem Jahr 2026 hier wieder als Host begrüßen darf. Ich begrüße euch und meine Gäste zu einer neuen Pickepacken-Folgen. Zu der Liga, die so keinen Verein wirklich verlassen will. Weder nach oben noch nach unten. Es gibt so ein paar Ausnahmen, aber sonst scheint es wieder so, als wollen einfach alle Teams in dieser Liga bleiben. Und damit erstmal welcome back und schon mal ein ganz großes Danke an Michi, der hier sehr spontan eingesprungen ist. Hallo Michi.
Hallo Eva, hallo Thorsten, hallo liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ich habe mich bereit erklärt einzuspringen für den Armin Thomas, der erkrankt ist, war das Spiel am Freitag. Ob das hier dann noch kommen? Wahrscheinlich zu viel für seinen geschundenen Körper.
Ja, auf jeden Fall gute Besserung an Thomas. Und wie gesagt, das lieben wir ja im All-Star-Team, dass hier immer wieder Leute spontan einspringen können. Und dann begrüße ich zum ersten Mal unser neustes Mitglied im All-Star-Team. Wir haben uns nämlich, wie einige Vereine, auch in der Winterpause ein bisschen erweitert und dürfen jetzt Thorsten Wiese vom Fortuna-Podcast gebrabbelrot-weiß in unseren Reihen begrüßen. Hallo Thorsten.
Ja, hellau in die Runde. Das muss ich diese Woche machen, denn das Karnevalswochenende steht bevor. Gekommen und zu bleiben, das ist das Motto in dieser Liga, ne?
Ja, fair. Wie gesagt, schön, dass du auch uns im Winter jetzt verstärkt hast. Und wir haben uns für die heutige Sendung jeweils drei Vereine ausgesucht, die im Jahr 2026 mit alten und neuen Problemen konfrontiert wurden und werden und Teams, deren Neustart oder deren Start in dieses Jahr richtig gut geglückt ist. Vor allem wollen wir eben auch über Teams sprechen, die jetzt in der letzten Sendung vor zwei Wochen nicht zur Sprache gekommen sind. Wir schaffen es jetzt nicht, über alle 18 Teams in diesen ersten zwei Folgen zu sprechen, aber wir haben uns eben noch mal ein paar ausgesucht und wir schauen natürlich dabei auch so ein bisschen darauf, was sich für die Teams bis Ende Januar eben auf dem Transfermarkt getan hat. Bei der letzten Folge war der ja noch nicht geschlossen und das ein oder andere Team hat da ja noch mal einen wichtigen Transfer oder einen nötigen Transfer getätigt. Bevor wir das aber tun, wollen wir auf zwei Partien gucken, die für ein Drittel der Tore an diesem Wochenende in der zweiten Liga verantwortlich waren. 36 sind, falls ich mich nicht verzählt habe, gefallen. Alleine 13 davon in den Partien in Fürth und in Darmstadt, wenn auch mit, vorsichtig ausgedrückt, sehr unterschiedlicher Torverteilung. Und ich würde sagen, wir starten einfach mal in Fürth. Ich gebe mal in aller Kürze, in Anführungszeichen, den Spielverlauf wieder und dann frage ich erst dich einmal, Thorsten, nach deinem Eindruck. Und dann haben wir ja das unfassbare Glück, dass jemand eingesprungen ist hier mit dem Michi, der dieses Spiel Freitagabend live im Stadion verfolgt hat und wir sehr froh sind, dass sich der Puls ein bisschen wieder beruhigt hat, um auch darüber zu sprechen. Also, schauen wir auf das Spiel. Bjarnazson, der bringt die Vierte in der 8. Minute in Führung. Allerdings sorgt ein Magdeburger Doppelschlag innerhalb von zwei Minuten für die Führung der Magdeburger. Das war allerdings nur der Anfang für eine positive Zeitspanne für die Magdeburger, für eine absolute Horror. 20 Minuten für die Vierte, nämlich zwischen der 13. und der 33. Minute, erzielt Magdeburg insgesamt fünf Tore. Drei davon allein durch Zuckowski, Arifi und Elvidi. Verkürzen das Ergebnis vor der Pause noch auf drei zu fünf. Also wir haben acht Tore in den ersten 45 Minuten gesehen. Kurz nach Wiederentwurf erzielt Latayev– ich hoffe, ich habe seinen Namen nicht komplett zerstört– dann noch das 4 zu 5. Allerdings bekommen wir jetzt kein zweistelliges Torespiel. Was wir aber haben, ist das ungedrehte Ergebnis der Hinrunde. Das Gewand führt ja mit 5 zu 4. Thorsten, einfach mal so, du spielst ja auch viel FIFA und Co. Wenn du Trainer von einer der beiden Mannschaften wärst, was würdest du dazu jetzt sagen?
Das ist interessant, dass du diese Frage stellst, denn ich habe mich auch gefragt, was ich als Heiko Vogel meiner Mannschaft in der Kabine jetzt gesagt hätte. Das ist ja nicht gemacht mit jetzt haue ich mal drauf. Das ist ja, sage ich mal, psychologisch überhaupt nicht zu erklären, was da passiert ist. Darum, das hätte mich wirklich interessiert. Also da wäre ich gerne in der Kabine gewesen bei dem Spiel. Ja, ansonsten ist eine ganz verrückte Dynamik, das hast du gerade schon erzählt, die da so auf sich gekommen ist. Der Ausgleich war ja vielleicht noch so ein bisschen unglücklich abgefälscht etc. Aber dann wurde ja so unfassbar luftig verteidigt, beziehungsweise dann irgendwann gar nicht mehr. Da hat man gesagt, naja, also die kommen zu gut durch, wir probieren es gar nicht mehr. Erst, ich möchte aber auch darauf hinweisen, dass Dominik Reimann ein Torwart ohne jegliche Strafenbeherrschung zu sein scheint, auf Magdeburger Seite. Drei Gegentore nach Ecken, wo er wirklich umher segelt. Und ich weiß das vom guten Thomas, also auch an dieser Stelle hier gute Besserung. Das ist nicht das erste Mal, dass das passiert ist. Also da sehe ich auch ein bisschen Problematik bei Magdeburg. Aber wir haben ja gleich den Fokus auch noch sehr stark da auf Fürth. Man ist natürlich so ein bisschen wiedergekommen. Ich glaube aber, das ist so ein psychologisches Moment, dass– ich sage das immer ganz gerne– nie zu früh zu hoch führen. Denn die andere Mannschaft hat dann irgendwann gar nichts mehr zu verlieren. Das gilt übrigens auch für Relegationen, aber da gehen wir heute nun wirklich nicht drauf ein. Wenn du halt so aussichtslos in Rücksstand bist, dann kannst du theoretisch als Trainer deinem Team ja immer sagen, Leute, das Kind ist in den Brunnen gefallen, der Druck ist weg. Jetzt gibt es nichts mehr zu verlieren. Versucht es einfach. Und das scheint dann so ein bisschen passiert zu sein, weil Magdeburg dann in dem Moment dann auch natürlich was irgendwie zu verlieren hatte. Und ja, für mich als neutralen Zuschauer, also so neutral man natürlich sein kann in dieser Liga, wo ja fast alle im Abstiegskampf sind, war das natürlich sehr, sehr unterhaltsam. Also ich hatte meinen Spaß, weil ich halt, sag ich mal so die Dramaturgie rein als Fußballfern genießen konnte und nicht im Stadion wahrscheinlich in den Seilen hängt.
Niki, bevor ich dir das Wort übergebe, ich kann ja auch kurz sagen, ich hatte mich Freitagabend verabredet zum Fußballgucken quasi und bin aber ein bisschen verspäteter los als geplant. Da dachte ich, komm, hier passiert schon nichts. Und ich hatte eine Strecke von 15 Minuten zu bewältigen, habe mir natürlich Sport-Show auf die Ohren geknallt, den Live-Kommentar und dachte dann aber auch so, ja, nee, klar. Und die Person, mit der ich das geguckt habe, war auch immer wieder so, was? Du hast eben erst gesagt, Thor, warum ist jetzt schon wieder ein Thor gefallen? Das ist zwar wirklich kurios.
Da kann ich noch ein bisschen was zu ergänzen, wo du gerade das Private erzählst. Ich hatte Partygäste am Freitagabend, die halt so circa zur zweiten Halbzeit kamen. Und ich bin über den Spielverlauf sehr, sehr glücklich, dass er genau so war, dass ich nämlich mit der zweiten Halbzeit fast gar nichts mehr verpasst habe. Zumindest aus meiner Sicht. Aber Michi kann mir da natürlich widersprechen.
Nee, ich musste da gar nicht widersprechen. Ich habe auch überlegt, ob die erste oder zweite Halbzeit aus Viertel aus meiner Sicht schlimmer war. Es ist ja immer so eine Diskussion. Man kommt in der 47. Minute ran auf 4 zu 5, hat das Momentum auf seiner Seite. Das Stadion ist wieder da, dass davor gespenstisch still war und wenn dann nur unterbrochen von lauten Magdeburggesängen oder von piffen der Heimfans. Und dann kommt man ran, der 47. hat eigentlich eine ganze Halbzeit Zeit, das 5 zu 5 zu machen oder dieses Spiel noch komplett auf seiner Seite zu ziehen. Und dann jetzt die nächste Torchance, die man hat, wieder nach einer Ecke in der 95. Minute. Man hätte ja fast noch den Ausgleich gemacht als Viertel. Der Neuenberger stark auf die Linie gerettet. Das brauchte dann sogar die Torlinientechnik. Der Ball war nicht ganz drüber. Aber dass man sich zwischen der 47. und der 95. keine Torchance mehr erspielt, spricht jetzt auch nicht unbedingt für die spielerische Qualität der Viertel. Und auch nicht für den Willen und unbedingt der Aufbäumen. Also da hat man auch nicht viel gesehen an Aufbäumen, fand ich. Also es gab eine Verletzungsunterbrechung. In der 85. zum Beispiel, da wurde Footcore länger behandelt und alle Viertel standen einfach auf dem Platz irgendwo rum. Und das war kein Aufbäumen, dass man sich nochmal zusammensetzt, dass man irgendeinen Plan ausheckt. Wirkte alles sehr, sehr leblos. Und vielleicht war die Kraft dann auch schon weg nach dieser ersten Halbzeit. Aber natürlich muss man aus Viertelsicht schon sagen, dass dieses Spiel– also die Essenz meines Zeitungsartikels nach dem Spiel war, dass man mehr als ein Fußballspiel verloren hat. Weil was wahrscheinlich in Deutschland gar nicht so bekannt ist, vor dem Spiel gab es in Fürth eine große Aktion von Vereinen, Fanszenen, Stadt, Hauptsponsoren, Spieler haben sich alle getroffen und haben sich quasi vereint, trotz aller Nebenkriegsschauplätze, die es hier gibt in Fürth, die wir auch schon oft hier diskutiert haben. In der letzten Folge war ja auch dieser Aufsichtsratsbrief zum Beispiel in der Folge drin. Das hat man quasi alles beiseite geschoben und hat sich darauf verständigt, jetzt alle Kräfte zu bündeln, sich für das gemeinsame Ziel Klassenerhalt zu vereinen. Und es gab einen Brief oder eine E-Mail der Fan-Abteilung, es wird nicht gepfiffen und wir bleiben hinter unserer Mannschaft, weil wir geben jetzt alles für den Klassenerhalt. Nach 33 Minuten kamen die ersten Pfiffe. Ich glaube, damit konnte man aber auch nicht rechnen, dass man fünf Gegentore in 20 Minuten bekommt. Aber dass man tatsächlich– also man gewinnt in Kiel vergangene Woche, muss kürze Vierteljahr auch dazu. Der erste Auswärtssieg seit dem Sieg in Bielefeld, Eva, so erinnerst du dich vielleicht. Das war im September, da saß ich im Polo-Hemp noch auf der Tribüne, es war sehr warm auf der Alm. Also da hatten wir einen Auswärtssieg bei Holstein Kiel. Dann macht man als Viert eigentlich in der Woche vieles, um die Gemeinschaft zu stärken. Man schießt das frühe Tor und dass man danach dann 5 Tore in 20 Minuten bekommt, ist einerseits erklärbar, weil man halt, wie wir gesehen haben, die schlechteste Abwehr der Liga hat. Das wurde da ja nochmal ganz offenbar, wie man da verteidigt hat. Es wurde auch hinterher viel diskutiert, woran das jetzt liegt. Ist es eine Systemfrage, ist es eine Haltungsfrage, eine Qualitätsfrage? Wahrscheinlich von Alm ein bisschen was. Viert hat in den letzten Spielen mit einer Dreikette gespielt, die war da defensiv stabiler. Da hat Heiko Vogel auf eine Viererkette umgestellt und die Viererkette auch mit zwei quasi neuen Verteidigern besetzt, also Bjarne Son und Elvedi. Bjarne Son lang verletzt, Elvedi vom FCK ausgeliehen in der letzten Transferwoche. Die Abstimmung hat dazu ganz gut gepasst, hat Elvedi hinterher gesagt, das hat man ganz gut gesehen, dass da an der Abstimmung ein paar Probleme gab. Aber das eine ist das Vierterverteidigen, das andere ist halt die Magdeburger spielerische Qualität und vor allem die Abschlussqualität von Mateusz Zuckowski. Also, gefühlt ist er ja wie aus dem Nichts gekommen, aus seiner Verletzung und dann diese Abschlüsse waren einfach extrem gut. Also, wenn er dann in den Ball gekommen ist, war das immer gefährlich. Er hat dann nochmal an die Latte auch geschossen, zwischen dem 1-4 und dem 1-5, bild ich mir ein. Also, es gab eine weitere Chance von Zuckowski und das war einfach, also für den Abstiegskampf ist das, für Magdeburg kann das schon ein Gamechanger sein, so einen Stürmer von drin zu haben, der einfach immer für Tore gut ist. Und wie Thorsten schon sagte, die Abwehr bei Magdeburg und vor allem der Torhüter beim ersten Gegentor, wo Rheinmann wieder rauskommt und dann am Ball vorbei wischt. Und man muss auch sagen, Föhrt hat drei Standardtore geschossen. Und das waren die ersten drei diese Saison. Also, hm, hm. Spricht auch nicht für Magdeburg, aber bevor ich noch weiter in weitere Illusion verfalle. Thorsten, du möchtest was sagen.
Ich wollte noch zwei Punkte ergänzen. Also, zum einen, Zulkowski jetzt bei neun Toren. Und die schießt er ja eher, gesagt, nicht seit Saisonbeginn, sondern erst seit Ende November so in etwa. Das heißt, also gerade in den letzten Spielen, als es bei Magdeburg läuft, ist eigentlich auch Zulkowski derjenige, der großen Anteil letztendlich daran hat. Und dann wollte ich noch einen Punkt anbringen, den hatte ich schon im Rasenfunk-Chat geschrieben. Fünf Neuzugänge bei Föhrt in der Startelf. Also auch sportlich wirklich als Neustart so ein bisschen, denke ich, gesehen, das Spiel. Wir haben uns ganz neu aufgestellt, jetzt greifen wir an. Dann ist das natürlich schon, ja, ein Debakel, muss man so sagen.
Ja, vor allem, also fünf, die jetzt im Winter kamen und Bjarne, der das Tor gemacht hat, war ja auch lang verletzt und hatte davor irgendwie fünf Spiele, glaube ich, in der Hinterhunde. Also faktisch ja auch ein Neuzugang, weil er einfach seit einem Monat nicht mehr mitgespielt hatte. Also dann eigentlich sechs, mehr als die halbe Mannschaft. Das spricht natürlich nicht für die Kaderplanung im vergangenen Sommer. Das spricht auch nicht für diese Formulierung, die man ja gerne hört. Wir vertrauen uns am Kader und bitten jetzt auf die Kritik, das wurde mir auch zugetragen. Man muss ein bisschen Vertrauen in den bestehenden Kader haben. Also ich glaube, man kann mehr Misstrauen in den Kader nicht äußern, als dass man einfach sechs oder fünf Winterzugänge in die Startelf stellt. Nachdem man ja eigentlich vier Punkte aus zwei Spielen geholt hat. Aber Heiko Vogel, ich konnte das schon auch verstehen. Also wann, wenn nicht in einem Heimspiel gegen den FC Magdeburg, als 18. Gegner gegen den 17. Heimspiel, dass man gewinnen muss, dass man sich auf seine eigenen Stärken besinnt und dann halt einfach auch offensiv aufstellt. Es ging jetzt fürchterlich nach hinten los. Wenn das Spiel gewonnen worden wäre, hätten alle gesagt, ja klar, da war der neue Geist. Der Trainer hat alles richtig gemacht. Da hat die Mannschaft neu eingestellt mit einer offensiven Wucht. Ich glaube da immer noch, dass da auch gute Zugänge dabei waren nach vörter Seite. Also, Altayev, das Tor, das macht nicht jeder Stürmer so. Ich habe ja in Fürth schon viele Stürmer gesehen. Der hat den Torhüter einfach angeschossen. Er macht es dann mit einem Chip über den Torhüter. Auch sonst viel Energie, gute Ballbehandlung. Die Frage ist halt, ob ein guter Offensivspiel erreicht, wenn man 52 Gegentore nach 21 Spielen hat. Das wäre hochgerechnet. Das ist noch ein letzter Fun-Fact dazu. Das ist für unseren eigenen Podcast mal hochgerechnet. Jan Regensburg hatte letztes Jahr 71 Gegentore. Die hatten ja so ein 3-8 gegen Nürnberg unter anderem dabei. Und ein 0-4 gegen Fürth. Die hatten 71 Gegentore. Wenn man für die einen vierter Schnitt hochrechnet, erwähnt es 84. Das könnte schwierig werden mit dem Klassen, wenn man es so weitermacht.
Du hast gerade Fun-Facts erwähnt. Ich habe noch ein bisschen was mitgebracht zur Partie. Also zum einen finde ich es bemerkenswert, der XG-Wert von beiden Teams liegt bei 1,56 und 1,61. Das ist ganz interessant, wenn 4 und 5 Tore jeweils fallen. Und auch interessant, die Anzahl der Schüsse aufs jeweilige Tor, 6 Schüsse zu 7 Schüsse. Also kein Spiel der Torhüter insgesamt, muss man dann an der Stelle leider sagen. Und ich habe dann noch mitgebracht, ich fand es ganz interessant, die Props gehen hier aber an den Kicker, der hat nämlich im Archiv gewühlt. Diese Partie war nämlich historisch. Es gab tatsächlich nur drei Partien in der 2. Liga, in der in der ersten Halbzeit ebenfalls 8 Tore fielen. Ihr habt sie wahrscheinlich parat. Ja, ist ja klar. Ich erwähne sie nur ganz kurz. Es war tatsächlich 74-75 Nürnberg gegen den FC Homburg, 5 zu 3 zur Halbzeit, 6 zu 5 das Endergebnis. Dann 78-79 Tennis Borussia Berlin gegen Fortuna Köln. Sehr interessant. Da stand es zur Halbzeit 5 zu 3 und es endete 5 zu 6 für Fortuna Köln. Du siehst also Michi, es wäre möglich gewesen, das Spiel zu drehen. Und die einzige Partie, bei der auch ich schon auf der Welt war, das war 96-97 Kaiserslautern gegen den SV Meppen. 6 zu 2 zur Halbzeit, Endergebnis 7 zu 6. Also die vierte kuriose Partie dieser Art. Übrigens nur einmal in der Bundesliga, dass es ebenfalls 8 Tore in der ersten Halbzeit gab, und zwar letzte Saison. Kommt ihr drauf, welches Spiel? Ich wusste es auch nicht vorher, aber dann fiel es mir sofort ein. Union Berlin gegen Stuttgart. 4 zu 4 nach 45 Minuten letzte Saison. Und dann habe ich entschieden, da lief es genau umgekehrt, dann habe ich mich entschieden zur zweiten Halbzeit letztes Jahr, diese Partie einzeln zu gucken. Ja, und dann ist natürlich nichts mehr passiert. Das nennt man das Mark-Schwitz-Geglück.
Ich glaube, ich musste das Spiel sogar covern für den Rasenfunk und habe das im Real-Life geguckt. Und das war mein Glück, weil ich konnte dann mir schön entspannende Spiele aussuchen, wo in der zweiten Halbzeit mehr gelaufen ist, um das parallel zu gucken. Also ja, Big Brain-Move, so etwas im Real-Life zu gucken.
Aber ich…
Tja, also sogar eine historische Partie, das wollte ich nur noch kurz angemerkt haben.
Ich glaube, alle, die im Stadion waren, waren glücklich, einer historischen Partie beigewohnt zu haben. Es gab auch mit vierter Verteidigung über dieses Spiel mit acht Toren. Die waren nicht in einer Halbzeit, aber vierter als Bundesligist auch. Ist noch gar nicht so lange her, wenn man sich in der Bilder schaut, denkt man, das könnte Jahrzehnte her sein. Aber ist auch noch gar nicht so lange her. Da haben sie damals 1 zu 7 bei Bayer Leverkusen verloren. Das ist auch super, als mir Max damals die Screenshots geschickt hat, wie die vierte Abwehrkette da so verteidigt hat. Und da gibt es gewisse Parallelen zu der Abwehrkette, die jetzt verteidigt hat. Aber Patrick Schick ist ja doch noch besser als Matthias Zuckowski.
Fair. Ja, in Bielefeld erinnert man sich, glaube ich, immer gegen... War das gegen Borussia Dortmund? Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau. Da stand es, glaube ich, zur Halbzeit 1-1. Und dann ging das Spiel aber noch 11 zu 1 für Dortmund aus. Da erinnert sich... Also ich war da noch nicht auf der Welt, aber ich glaube, Wolfgang Kneipp erzählt da immer ganz gerne von, dass er an dem Tag durch die Bielefelder Altstadt gegangen ist. Und jedes Geschäft, was er weiterging, da gab es natürlich noch keine Smartphones, aber soweit da ging, kam dann doch immer eine Kneipe weiter, gab es dann immer das nächste Gegentor. Auch ganz toll. Weirder Abschweifung auch. Aber ich glaube, wir können erstmal festhalten, von einem Team, da haben wir eben schon erwartet, dass die eigentlich fast tot geglaubt waren. Und das ist der erste FCM und da muss man einfach sagen, die haben sich da richtig rausgekämpft und stehen eben überm Strich mit 23 Punkten. Erstmal, also es war noch ein bisschen höher, aber das ist wirklich, wir haben alleine 4 Teams mit 24 Punkten, dann 23, 22, 21 und 19. Also das ist auch alles gut, nah beieinander, ehrlich gesagt. Ich möchte diese Tabelle momentan nicht wirklich in, das ist noch Abstiegskampf und das ist schon Aufstiegskampf und das ist Tabellenmittelfeld. Das Tabellenmittelfeld ist Lava. Also wir können gleich, wir sprechen vielleicht jetzt über eine Mannschaft, die ist vielleicht so ein bisschen das Personifizierte, wenn auch nicht wirklich tabellarische Mittelfeld. Aber du kannst dich wirklich auf gar nichts ausruhen und das werden wir, glaube ich, alle noch sehen. Ich weiß, ich wiederhole mich da immer, aber so zwei, drei Spiele können halt auch wirklich einfach immer den absoluten Unterschied machen und auch einfach die Laune und den Sicht der Dinge auf die komplett verändern. Und ich glaube, wir können sagen, Sicht der Dinge hat eben auch 230 Kilometer gen Nordwesten sich geändert. Es war nämlich in Darmstadt. Die hatten das Samstagabendspiel und hatten Kaiserslautern zu Gast. Gefühlt hat Darmstadt super viele Samstagabendspiele. Ich weiß nicht, ob nur mir das so geht, aber in die Spiele gefühlt immer Samstagabend. Und es war eben ein sehr, sehr deutliches 4 zu 0 für den SVD. Hornby in der fünften Minute vom Punkt lagen, Macher in der 29. und Kläfisch in der 45. Machen ja dieses Spiel, auch wenn man das Freitagabendspiel im Hintergrund hatte, eigentlich schon in der ersten Halbzeit zu. Marseiler setzt dann in der 90. plus zwei, dann den Schlusspunkt. Kaiserslautern eigentlich über 90 Minuten ungefährlich, vorsichtig ausgedrückt. Darmstadt, die schieben sich jetzt an Schalke vorbei auf Platz eins. Zementiert seine Heimstärke, kein einziges Spiel verloren zu Hause in dieser Saison und seit Anfang November jedes Heimspiel auch gewonnen. Michi, einfach mal so die Frage an dich. Hast du erwartet, dass wir Darmstadt da jetzt mit als eins der besten Teams oben gerade Thron sehen?
Ja, das ist natürlich jetzt einfach zu sagen nach dem, was du gesagt hast. Ich habe sie aber bei einem dieser Heimsiege gesehen, die sie da gefeiert haben in der Hinrunde. Sie haben gegen Fürth nämlich gespielt und ich war da live im Stadion und das war ein sehr reifer Auftritt, das SV Darmstadt. Ein insgesamt einfach sehr guter Auftritt, auch wenn Florian Kohfeldt da noch einiges zu bemäkeln hatte natürlich. Da haben sie aber 4 zu 2 gewonnen, am Ende auch sehr souverän und als sie lagen mal eins, zwei kurz mal hinten, da hat man gesehen, okay, es läuft vielleicht noch nicht alles gut, aber vor allem diese offensive Qualität mit Hornby und Liedberg, aber auch die defensive Stabilität einfach mit dieser gefühlt 4 Meter großen Innenverteidigung, also auf jeder Stelle der Innenverteidigung, gefühlt 4 Meter groß. Das Zentrum mit Klefisch und Akiyama, das extrem gut ist, was dazu geführt hat, dass sie Darmstädter Paul Will nach Fürth ausgeliehen haben, der hier aussieht, als wäre der beste Spieler sofort in der Mannschaft und der ist halt ein Satz Spieler vom SV Darmstadt. Die Kaderbreite ist einfach auch gut beim SV Darmstadt. Und für mich waren sie zusammen mit der SV Elversberg in der Hinrunde die beste Mannschaft, die ich gesehen habe. Ich hatte alle 17 Spiele der Spielveranstaltung gesehen. Insofern ja auch 16 andere Mannschaften und da war der SV Darmstadt dabei. Insofern ist es völlig legitim, dass sie da oben stehen und ich glaube, sie werden auch sehr lange, wenn nicht sogar bis zum Ende, da oben stehen, weil da einfach sehr vieles sehr gut läuft und weil sie natürlich nicht den Druck haben, den anderen Standort aufsteigen zu müssen. Da kommt man vielleicht noch auf andere Vereine auf dieser Sendung.
Thorsten, wie sieht es bei dir aus? Also, kann ich dich auch gerne zu Darmstadt anschließen?
Ja, also, ich würde da tatsächlich auch den Begriff der Machtdemonstration mal einfach hier in den Raum werfen, denn die Ambitionen von Lautern sind ja eigentlich die höheren als bei Darmstadt. Zumindest nach außen hin gibt man sich da ja doch zurückhaltend und das ist jetzt aus eigener Erfahrung auch nicht die dümmste Strategie, um das Thema möglichen Aufstieg anzugehen. Ich war sehr beeindruckt, ich habe das Spiel gesehen. Man darf ja auch nicht vergessen, Litberg hat gefehlt wegen einer Verletzung, aber Lakenmacher hat ihn im Grunde also problemlos ersetzt, hat ja auch das 2-0 dann erzielt. Und auch hier komme ich wieder mit meinen XG-Werten. Also, die allein zur Pause hatte Lautern einen XG-Wert von 0,1. Dann weißt du halt, die haben nicht stattgefunden. Und so war es im Grunde über die gesamte Partie. Ich finde, der Unterschied wurde schon deutlich. Das war spielerisch eine Klasse besser als Kaiserslautern. Und das ist tatsächlich auch so mein Eindruck. Michi, du hast ja auch gerade gesagt, ich habe es ja auch alle einmal live gesehen, schon dieses Jahr. Ich mache gerade die zweite Runde sozusagen voll. Und Darmstadt war in Düsseldorf sehr, sehr dominant damals auch. Und am Ende war es ein verdienter 3-0-Sieg in der Hinrunde. Ja, jetzt in der Rückserie, im nächsten Heimspiel, da könnte natürlich für Darmstadt die erste Heimniederlage dann folgen. Ich verrate mal nicht, gegen wen sie spielen werden. Aber im Moment würde ich sagen, ist Darmstadt tatsächlich das Maß aller Dinge spielerisch in dieser Liga. Das überrascht insofern schon. Ich habe immer so ein bisschen negative Meinung von Florian Kohfeldt gehabt, dass es so ein typischer Trainer ist, der so am Anfang einen sehr guten Eindruck macht. Er ist ja auch eloquent, rhetorisch gut, was er so sagt. Er gibt auch Hand und Fuß. Aber wenn man dann auf Bremen guckt oder auch auf Wolfsburg oder ich glaube, Eupen war in Belgien, da ist es dann nach so einer kurzen Anfangszeit immer runtergegangen. Und die Kurve hatte diesmal scheinbar in Darmstadt nicht. Da war es am Anfang hoch, dann war es holprig und jetzt geht es wieder besonders hoch. Also ich glaube, mit Darmstadt ist zu rechnen, genauso wie du gesagt hast, Michi, weil sie eben diesen Druck nicht haben. Das ist in einer Liga, die wirklich so eng beieinander ist, wo es auch einfach auf Tagesform teilweise ankommt, ist das ein Faustfand. Der einzige Nachteil ist vermutlich für einen Verein wie Darmstadt, dass die Trauben in der Bundesliga dann meistens ein bisschen zu hoch hängen, weil du eben dann finanziell dich da sehr sehr schwer tust. Aber das ist natürlich alles Zukunftsmusik und da muss man jetzt ja auch noch nicht schwarz malen. Ich glaube, in Darmstadt sind ja einfach alle gerade happy, dass das Team gut spielt. Ja und Kaiserslautern, da ist es glaube ich umgekehrt so. Und wir wissen glaube ich alle, wie wackelig der Trainerstuhl in Kaiserslautern ist. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass Thorsten Lüberknecht jetzt schon fällig ist. Aber Thomas Heng ist da nun wirklich keiner, der da lange zögert, wenn etwas nicht so richtig läuft. Jetzt, ich glaube Rückrundentabelle waren vier Punkte jetzt aus vier Spielen. Also einen Sieg haben sie am ersten Rückrundenspieltag gegen Hannover, aber auch sehr begünstigt durch eine rote Karte. Werden wir vielleicht umgekehrt auch noch bei Hannover drüber sprechen heute. Und ansonsten fand ich das, also bei Schalke haben sie 2-0 geführt und dann 2-2 gespielt. Und Schalke ist natürlich seine ganz eigene Geschichte. Ansonsten gegen Elbersberg haben sie nämlich auch schon spielerisch ihre Grenzen aufgezeigt bekommen. Und das ist eigentlich so mein Take bei Kaiserslautern, dass es spielerisch fürs Spitzenteam nicht ganz reicht. Da sind sie einfach nicht auf dem Niveau, dass Hannover, dass Elbersberg, dass Darmstadt haben. Schalke schon. Schalke ist ein ganz anderes Ding. Aber darum sind sie– und ich glaube, da wolltest du eingangs eben hinaus drauf, Eva– darum sind sie gerade der Mittelfeldplatz der 2. Liga. Platz 7 ist das Mittelfeld. 6 ist Aufstiegskampf, 8 ist Abstiegskampf.
Ja, also wir können einmal, um es eben auch tabellarisch zu machen, das sind eben 8 Punkte Rückstand auf Tabellenplatz 3, 9 Punkte auf Platz 16. Also ich glaube, ja, wir haben noch ein bisschen was zu spielen, aber ich glaube, es hilft wirklich überhaupt nicht, was da gerade im Hintergrund passiert. Also das hat jemand eben auch im Rasenfunk Forum geschrieben zu den Inputs, zu den 2 Ligatouren, dass es eben, man so ein bisschen das Gefühl hat bei Kaiserslautern, da fehlt auch die Rückendeckung, also Hängen, der ganz offensiv ehrlich gesagt auch irgendwie jeden kritisiert, wo man denkt, na ja, okay, aber für die Kader-Zusammenstellung bist halt am Ende des Tages du zuständig. Also den Kader mit dem Thorsten-Lieberknecht arbeitet, das ist dein Kader am Ende des Tages und da muss man auch sagen, also auch die Eindrücke, die Leute vom Lieberknecht oder vom Lieberknecht von der PK geschildert haben, die wirken sehr, also gerade für Darmstadt-Fans sehr vergleichsweise zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo Thorsten-Lieberknechts Zeit in Darmstadt eben vorbei ging. Auch das darf man ja nicht vergessen, auch da gibt es ja durchaus Historie und ja, also es ist eben kein gutes Zeichen, vor allem ist es, also wir sind 4 Spieltage rein in dieses neue Jahr. Du die letzten, du hast Ende März noch eine Länderspielpause, die ist meiner Meinung nach für Vereine wie Kaiserslautern, um dann irgendwie nochmal eine Stellschraube zu drehen, fast zu weit weg. Also wenn du halt wirklich sagst, willst du was verändern, hast du den besten Zeitpunkt mit der Winterpause verpasst. Und der nächste, der kommt erst, wenn du, falls du wirklich intern mal gesagt hast, du möchtest gerne um den Aufstieg mitspielen, dann hast du dann schon verpasst und Michi möchte gerne was dazu sagen.
Ja, was die Personalie Thorsten Lieberknecht angeht natürlich, es gibt am kommenden Wochenende ein Heimspiel des 1. FC Kaiserslautern gegen einen mir gut bekannten Verein. Also ich kann mir schon vorstellen, wenn das nochmal schiefgehen sollte, dass man auch dann schon reagiert. Also wenn man halt gegen den Tabellenletzten zu Hause verliert, klar, die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist nicht allzu hoch. Andererseits hat mir ein gut bekannter Mensch aus Kaiserslautern schon geschrieben, dass er ein El Crisico erwartet. Eine schöne Wortneuschöpfung für dieses Spiel. Und natürlich werden beide Mannschaften darauf aussehen, das hat der Julian Krale, finde ich, in einem beachtlichen Interview, hat in bemerkenswerter Klarheit auch gesagt, dass es gar nicht ging für Kürzdi auftritt und dass sie dann ein anderes Gesicht zeigen müssen. Ja, aber man weiß ja auch, dass dieses Stadion, dieser Verein, können einen beflügen, die können einen aber auch lähmen, wenn das mal da nicht läuft. Und wenn man zu Hause ging, dabei den Letzten spielen muss, der auch gemerkt hat, er ist momentan besser, wenn er sich mal ganz tief in den Reihen stellt, den Mannschaftsbus vor das Tor stellt. Und der FCK muss mit dem, was ihr gerade angesprochen habt, mit der spielerischen, sagen wir mal, nicht ausgeprägtesten Form, dagegen einen tiefstehenden Block spielen. Und dann wird es unruhig im Stadion, dann kommt ein Konter und die Viertel machen, wie auch immer, das 1-0. Dann kann da auch ganz schnell noch mehr Unruhe aufkommen, als es eine ganz gefährliche Situation der FCK ist. Plus, wie ich auch schon gesagt habe, der FCK hat andere Ambitionen, die sind natürlich auch finanziell untermauert. Der FCK hat einen anderen Etat und zahlt andere Gehälter. Das hört man immer wieder als andere Zweitligisten. Da muss irgendwann noch mal der nächste Step kommen, weil man einfach so viel Invest leistet. Wenn der ausbleibt, dann ist meist leider der Trainer das schwächste Glied. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, falls es schiefgeht, dass das dann der Zeitpunkt wäre, wenn da kein Sieg gegen Führer ausspringt.
Guter Punkt.
Ich wollte noch ergänzen, dass natürlich auf der einen Seite das Auftaktprogramm in die Rückrunde jetzt auch wirklich nur aus Spitzen-Teams bestand. Also sie haben gegen Hannover, Schalke, Elvesberg und Darmstadt gespielt. Aber das ist natürlich auch eine Standortbestimmung. Und du hast jetzt also sozusagen außer gegen Hannover all die direkten Duelle nicht für dich entscheiden können. So dass das natürlich auch ein bisschen wegweisend ist. Und ja, jetzt, wie du sagst, jetzt kommt das Heimspiel gegen Fürth. Da werden sie liefern müssen. Oder ja, dann geht das schnell in Lautern. Also das Interview mit Thomas Hengen, der war in der Halbzeit, der war schon sehr angenervt. Ja, hat dann aber auch nur so allgemein Plätze rausgehauen, wie er müsste jetzt mal hier Männerfußball sehen. Ich lasse das mal unkommentiert so stehen. Tiefe Analysen, also auch in Kaiserslautern.
Ja, ein Punkt vielleicht noch zu Kaiserslautern. Ich glaube, bei denen ist halt auch wirklich so ein bisschen das Problem, das Gesicht, was sie auswärts zeigen. Also Michi, du hast schon zu Recht gesagt, was Heim dann abgeht. Aber also ich weiß, ich bringe das immer wieder voran. Aber wir hatten dieses 0-0 in Bielefeld, wo sie sich halt, ehrlich gesagt, wirklich 90 Minuten hinten reingestellt haben. Und da ging nichts. Dann hattest du dieses, das war dann das letzte Auswärtsspiel bis halt zu dem Schalke-Spiel, wo du dachtest, okay, wenn das dazu geführt hat, dass wir so einen Kaiserslautern auswärts sehen, war vielleicht der richtige Schritt für die Leute, die dieses Spiel gesehen haben, vielleicht nicht das Beste. Aber eben gegen Schalke hat man eben schon ein anderes Kaiserslautern gesehen. Aber dann in Darmstadt wieder so aufzutreten, so komplett passiv und eigentlich von der ersten Minute nicht wirklich da und auch keine wirkliche Gegenwehr in der zweiten Hälfte zu zeigen, das ist eben das, wo man dann doch wahrscheinlich irgendwann guckt, ja, okay, sehe ich dann schon irgendwie auch eine Berechtigung, über den Trainer zu sprechen, weil man sagt, okay, solche taktischen Kniffe, die müssen Gründer haben und wenn die nicht aufgehen, dann hinterfragst du das natürlich und ja, das ist, glaube ich, einfach das große Problem. Und wenn man natürlich zurückguckt, welche Trainer schon so entlassen wurden in den letzten Jahren, weil es ja mit dem Zielaufstieg nichts wurde, ihr habt das schon richtig benannt, dann muss man fast fragen, also da weiß man natürlich nie, was die Interna sind, was Thomas Hengens Interna da auch quasi betrifft. Das hat man ja auch schon länger mal vermutet, dass das bei ihm dann auch irgendwann mal der letzte Griff rund um den Trainerposten gewesen sein muss, weil das muss man ja auch ehrlich sagen, irgendwann musst du eben auch den Sportdirektor hinterfragen. Aber ja, da bin ich prinzipiell mal gespannt. Ja, Thorsten, sag gerne noch was.
Doch, einen Punkt wollte ich nur noch anmerken, weil wir ja auch ein bisschen noch auf die Wintertransfers schauen und die sprechen natürlich auch bei Lautern wirklich noch mal eine ganz klare Sprache. Also zum einen, das haben wir noch nicht so richtig erwähnt, Bretalien hat sich jetzt verletzt, der schon der entscheidende Spieler vor allem in der Hinrunde war und auch der herausragende Mann, den sie aber auf dem Papier nicht minder schlecht mit Mérgine Berisha jetzt ersetzt haben. Ich meine, der hat immerhin auch ein Länderspiel für Deutschland mal absolviert in seiner Hochphase beim FC Augsburg. Ist eine Weile her, die Älteren erinnern sich. Und aber jetzt auch mit Jakob Rasmussen von RB Salzburg, also einen Stammspieler geholt von dort, wohlgemerkt für die Abwehr. Und es ist halt bisher noch gar nicht aufgegangen. Was halt auch wieder zeigt, dass man solche Dinge ja nicht so übers Knie brechen kann. Also man kann eben nicht immer mit dem Holzhammer versuchen, jetzt unbedingt oben mitzuspielen. Also klar, manchmal klappt das, dass du das Geld überall drauf wirfst. Aber wenn man das jetzt vergleicht, wir haben ja über Darmstadt eben gerade in dieser Partie gesprochen, da ist es halt gefühlt alles viel mehr gewachsen. Das ist es jetzt ja nicht nochmal durch Transfers so erzwungen, sondern es ist so ein viel organischerer Prozess. Während man in Lautern das Gefühl hat, da ist diese High-and-Fire-Mentalität nicht nur bei den Trainern, sondern auch bei den Spielern. Da wird eigentlich ständig, jetzt fast schon im Halbjahresrhythmus ausgetauscht und gehofft, dass das alles besser wird. Aber da kann ich nur zu sagen, als ein Verein, der halt auch seine Leistungsträger immer durchaus lukrativ abgibt, das klappt halt nicht immer. Und das führt dann auf Sicht dazu, dass du den Zielen leider immer ein bisschen hinterherläufst. Und genau das, finde ich, kann man gerade in Kaiserslautern beobachten.
So, ich kann jetzt schon mal sagen, wir haben unseren von mir vorausgestellten Zeitplan lockerflockig überschritten. Von daher trotzdem natürlich der Vollständigkeit teilbar, noch die Frage, ob ihr noch eine Partie habt, über die ihr sprechen wollt. Ich meine, für Marc erwähne ich einmal, man hat jetzt auch mal in der Liga den Angstgegner, die SV E mit 3-0 besiegen können. Und hat dabei ausnahmsweise mal all das irgendwie aufs Feld gebracht, was die Partien davor fehlte. Also man hat glaube ich nicht sein bestes Spiel gezeigt, dafür aber war man sehr effektiv unterwegs und hat 3-0 gewonnen. Eben das, was einem davor wirklich gefehlt hat und konnte da so ein bisschen die Durststrecke hinter sich lassen. Sonst...
Großartiger Torjugel von Toni Leistner. Seine Vorwärtsrolle mit Pistolero. Ich glaube, da hatte er ganz viele Gefühle auf einmal und wusste gar nicht, was er da machen sollte, weil er ein Tor geschossen hat. Und ich fand es sehr süß, wie so ein bisschen die Rabaleipzig-Platte gedreht wurde oder diese Hoffenheim-Platte. Ja, wir sind doch hier dieser kleine Verein und warum liebt ihr uns denn nicht alle? Wir versuchen doch schön Fußball zu spielen. Jetzt kommt die große Härte und mauert sich zum Sieg. Finde ich immer schwierig. Ich glaube, Zimmaschiet hat es nach dem Spiel so gesagt. Finde ich immer schwierig, wenn man, wenn man das so herausarbeiten möchte, dass man ja hier so der kleine Dorfverein ist, obwohl jeder weiß, dass das natürlich ohne großes Geld, dass da natürlich durch die Hülo-Augentropfen reinkommt, so auch nicht möglich wäre. Aber das vielleicht nur so. Am Rande zwei Worte zu dieser Partie.
Ja, fairer Punkt. Und man muss natürlich auch sagen, also Elversberg hat ja sonst auch gegen Hertha gewonnen. Also nach dem Pokalspiel war es, glaube ich. Nee, es war auf jeden Fall ein Dienstagabendspiel. Daran erinnere ich mich noch, wo man Elversberg dann besiegt hat. Doch, das war das Pokalspiel. Da hat man jetzt das zweite Spiel auch gegen die SVE gewinnen können, was sicherlich für viele Hertha-Fans eine Erleichterung war. Ich würde sonst sagen, wenn ihr keine weiteren Partien habt, wir schauen ja jetzt noch ein bisschen auf sechs Vereine, sind wir jetzt auch mal dazugekommen, die bisher, und wir wollen mit denen starten, die bisher eben Probleme haben und auch vielleicht auch welche, wo man es vor zwei Wochen noch nicht so gesehen hat oder eben noch nicht die Notwendigkeit gesehen hat. Und wir beginnen tatsächlich ein wenig provokant, es mag Leute etwas verwundern, aber bei Schalke 04. Ich weiß, sie stehen auf Platz zwei, sie haben ihre 40 Punkte, 12 Siege, 4 Unentschieden und 5 Niederlagen. Aber man muss eben sagen, in der Formtabelle in den letzten vier Spielen steht Schalke 04 auf Platz 17. Nur Preuß und Münster ist schlechter und hat weniger Punkte geholt. Man hat nämlich vier Unentschieden, eine Niederlage, wenn ich das jetzt richtig notiert habe, das sind nicht die letzten vier Spiele. Hervorragend. Es sind natürlich drei Unentschieden, eine Niederlage. Klar, es ist immer gut, wenn man seine eigenen Notizen nicht richtig interpretieren kann. Man muss ja sagen, erst die 02 Niederlage im Ruhrport-Duell gegen Bochum und jetzt ein 2-2 gegen Dresden nach 2-0 Führung. Der letzte Sieg, der war gegen den FCN am 14.12. Und man muss auch sagen, man hat in zwei Spielen jetzt ein Viertel seiner Gegentore bekommen. Also die Position, die bisher so am meisten rausgestochen hat bei Schalke 04, nämlich die Defensive, die hinkt jetzt auch so ein bisschen hinterher. Und Thorsten, dabei war doch bei Schalke die Laune, der Hype mit, so ging es in die letzte Folge mit Marc, ein der Edin Dzeko Hype und sowieso. Und was passiert jetzt mit Schalke und dieser Liga? Man muss leider sagen, trotz Doppelpack Edin Dzeko hat es hier gegen den Abstiegskandidaten nicht zu einem Sieg gereicht und man wartet eben schon seit einiger Zeit auf einen Sieg. Was ist denn los beim ESM4?
Ja, du hast natürlich einen wichtigen Punkt gerade schon genannt, das Schalker Bollwerk ist nicht mehr ganz so bollwerkig. Denn zehn Gegentore in der Hinrunde und jetzt schon sechs in nur vier Spielen der Rückrunde, das zeigt natürlich ganz klar, wo der Schuh drückt. Edin Dzeko ist nun wirklich nicht das Problem. Das hat man auch gegen Dresden gesehen. Ich meine, Schalke, eigentlich spielen sie ja auch längere Zeit, ich würde jetzt sagen, fast ihr bestes Rückrundenspiel und gehen da auch durchaus nicht unverdient 2-0 in Führung. Vor allem das zweite Tor war einfach so ein Tor, das schießt nicht jeder Zweite, nicht jeder Zweitliga-Spieler. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das vor Augen habt, wo Dzeko den Ball mit der Sohle kurz nach unten annimmt und aus einer fließenden Bewegung, aus 16, 17 Metern das Ding dann einschweißt. Da muss ich dann auch sagen, ganz neutral einfach ein klasse Tor einfach toll gemacht. Also Dzeko ist definitiv angekommen und es ist definitiv ein Transfer, der Schalke jetzt schon weiterhilft. Aber in der Partie konnte man auch beobachten, als Dzeko runterging, so nach circa glaube ich 60 Minuten, da ging auch ein Ruck und zwar nicht im positiven Sinne durch die Schalker Mannschaft, denn da kam Dresden auf einmal auf. Es ist nicht so, dass Dresden von Schalke an die Wand gespielt wurde, denn Spoiler, Schalke spielt niemanden an die Wand in dieser Liga. Das muss man fairerweise auch sagen. Schalke kommt über andere Eigenschaften, eben diese vor allem unfassbare Defensivstärke, die ihn jetzt aber leider abhandengekommen ist. Ja, und dann ist das so diese typische Dynamik. Ich habe eben auch schon über frühe Führungen oder höhere Führungen gesprochen. Das 2-1 fällt dann durch das Eigentor und dann macht Karius den Reimann beim 2-2 und springt ehrlicherweise auch an der Flanke vorbei. Und ich glaube, man wusste selber nicht, warum das Spiel jetzt auf einmal hier 2-2 steht, so nach dem Motto. Aber Schalke hat halt einfach nach der Auswechslung von Schilco nicht mehr so viel PS auf die Straße bekommen. Und ich glaube, wenn man von dem Spiel jetzt ein bisschen weggeht, woran liegt es denn? Ich glaube, bei Schalke ist halt das große Problem, dass die Anspruchshaltung sich jetzt doch deutlich geändert hat. Ich meine, wir erinnern uns einfach ein halbes Jahr zurück. Schalke hat eine miserable letzte Saison gespielt. Ich glaube, sogar historisch miserabel in der 2. Liga. Und im Grunde war die Erwartungshaltung auch bei den Schalkern so. In meinem Umfeld war ja Hauptsache nicht wieder so schlimm wie letztes Jahr. Und das bekam man ja relativ schnell. Also wir haben jetzt viel über negative Dinge gesprochen, aber Schalke ist nach wie vor die Mannschaft mit den meisten gewonnenen Kopfballduellen, den meisten Sprints der Liga, Platz 3 bei intensiven Läufen. Also du bekommst sehr viel. Naja, ich sag's jetzt mal, man nennt es ja manchmal so, es soll jetzt auch nicht zu suffisant klingen, also den talentfreien Bereichen, wo es also sehr viel um Arbeitseinstellungen, um Fleiß geht und all diese Dinge. Und das hat Muslice ja sehr gut hinbekommen. Und mit Muslice kam ja auch im Sommer da einfach ein Trainer, der charismatisch ist, der auch so ein bisschen das war, wonach die Schalker, glaube ich, nach den letzten zwei Jahren gesucht haben, ohne den vorherigen Trainern zu nahe treten zu wollen. Aber da wurde jetzt nicht so unfassbar viel hergemacht, vielleicht in der Ausstrahlung. Und ich glaube, da war man einfach seelig, dass es jetzt einfach besser lief. Da war eben auch ein bisschen egal, dass der Fußball nicht so toll ist. Ich meine, man ist immer noch letzter. Der Ballbesitzstatistik und bei der Passquote eine 74-prozentige Passquote ist wirklich nicht gut. Aber das war ein bisschen der Stil und das wurde alles natürlich auch gerechtfertigt, nicht nur durch die Erfolge und Siege, sondern vor allem, weil man halt hinten nichts zulief und ließ. Und wenn einem das jetzt verloren geht, dann hast du natürlich ein Problem. Und ich glaube, das kommt halt daher, dass jetzt natürlich die Chance gewittert wurde, von der Vereinsführung auch, jetzt haben wir halt eine realistische Chance aufzusteigen. Lass uns versuchen, das zu sichern und das machst du natürlich durch Transfers. Und auf einmal wird eine Mannschaft, die jetzt ehrlicherweise gar nicht so die Superstars vorher hatte, die bekommt jetzt welche. Mit Tseko, aber auch mit Ljubicic und auf einmal spürt natürlich auch das Team, ja, wir sind Erster. Das haben sie jetzt verspielt so ein bisschen. Und man kennt das aus dem Fußball, wenn du was zu verlieren hast, dann rattert halt der Kopf. Ich hatte es eingangs schon mal gesagt, das ist eine Liga, die ist so eng. Wenn der Kopf nicht genau in die Richtung denkt, die du brauchst, dann sind das Prozente, die fehlen. Und ich finde diesen Prozess, den sieht man gerade bei Schalke, doch sehr gut. Man hat was zu verlieren, die Ansprüche sind gestiegen, die Leute werden so ein bisschen unruhig und vielleicht gibt es auch ein bisschen, naja, ich will nicht Neid sagen, aber teamintern kommt das vielleicht hier und da auch nicht so gut, dass da halt einfach, nachdem man so eine erfolgreiche Hinserie hatte, jetzt neue Leute reinkommen und die spielen auf einmal von Anfang an und andere denken sich vielleicht, ja Moment mal, ich habe doch hier super gespielt in der Hinrunde, wieso sitze ich denn jetzt auf einmal auf der Bank? Ist ein bisschen Spekulation dieser Punkt, aber ich finde, wenn man das so als ein Cocktail sieht, ich glaube, das ist so eine Mischung aus diesen Dingen, die ich jetzt genannt habe, die dafür sorgen und durchaus lange Antwort auf deine Frage, Eva, woran hat es gelegen bei Schalke, aber ich glaube, das ist so diese Mischung, die gerade die Probleme so ein bisschen herbeiführt.
Michi, ergänzt gerne, du wirkst schon so bereit, deinen Teil dazu beizusteuern.
Ja, Thorsten hat natürlich schon sehr viele, sehr richtige Dinge angesprochen und das sind auch die wahrscheinlichsten Erklärungsansätze, warum es nicht funktioniert. Wenn man sich aber auch mal anschaut, 26 Tore als ehemaliger Tabellen-Erster. Die beiden Abschiebskandidaten haben mehr Tore geschossen. Also klar, der Edinciko-Hype ist da, aber er hat jetzt auch, glaube ich, drei von vier Rückrundentoren geschossen, wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe. Also wenn Edinciko nicht spielt, wenn Edinciko ausgewechselt wird, hat man auch da gemerkt, dass dann nicht mehr viel zusammengeht. Und auch da wieder die anekdotische Evidenz. Ich habe sie einmal gesehen in der nächsten Saison. Das fand ich auch offensiv extrem blass. Also da haben sie gegen Fürth gespielt, ich erinnere euch, 52 Gegentore. In der Saison bislang Schalke hat da nur eins dazu beigetragen und das war auch irgendwie in der 75. oder so. Bis dann haben sie sich extrem schwer getan. Und sie haben halt offenbar einen Plan A. Und wenn der funktioniert, dann ist alles super. Sie haben aber keinen Plan B. Was passiert, wenn der mal nicht funktioniert? Und das mit einem doch individuell hoch veranlagten Kader, mit einem Edinciko und so weiter, könnte man auch erwarten, dass mehr geht. Das wird auch, glaube ich, die Aufgabe für die nächsten Wochen sein, etwas zu entwickeln, damit man wieder die Spur findet. Also rein von der individuellen Qualität kann man natürlich aufsteigen. Die Erwartungshaltung ist immer noch groß, sie ist größer geworden, das habe ich dir richtig gesagt. Aber wenn wir wieder auf Darmstadt blicken, die haben diese Erwartungshaltung nicht. Und wenn man da befreiter aufspielen kann, ohne die Last eines 60.000 Menschen Stadions, das leicht zu begeistern ist, das aber auch manchmal zur Last werden kann. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich habe mich ja vor ein, zwei Folgen hier mal, als ich zu Gast war, weit aus dem Fenster gelesen, habe gesagt, das wirkt alles so super. Und Miron Muslic, der super Trainer, perfekt dafür, das ganze Umfeld zu befrieden mit seinen Ansprachen und seinen Reden. Und auch da, wenn man so ein bisschen quer liest, dann gibt es da schon auch wieder so Zweifeljahre, dass er doch immer die gleiche Platte, die er hat und so weiter. Und das ist immer nur auch, sagen wir mal, rhetorisch immer gleich. Ich finde es immer noch gut. Ich finde immer noch in den letzten Jahren der beste Trainer in der FC Schalke. Deswegen spielen sie auch eine gute Saison. Ich bin sehr gespannt, ob sie das durchhalten, wenn dann noch andere Vereine da so weitermachen, wie sie es tun. Einen haben wir schon angesprochen, der SV Darmstadt, ein zweiter kommt noch, ein kleiner Spoiler, eine kleine 2. Mannschaft, die sehr gut gerade in Form ist. Und wenn man dann irgendwann 3. wird, wir wissen, wie schwierig das ist, dann gegen einen Bundesligist in der Relegation zu spielen. Und wenn man nach dieser Hinrunde…
Was?
Ich weiß nicht, was ich meine. Relegation, beste Erfindung, EU West.
Ja, genau.
Aber nur zwischen 2. und 3. Liga, oder?
Super, alles super.
Ah, nee, auch nicht.
SV Wiesbaden, SV Wien, Wiesbaden.
Ja, ja. Und Darmstadt, also finde ich super. Konzeptrelegation möchte ich gerne für immer als MVP beibehalten. Finde ich super.
Ich wollte anäktotisch noch was zu dir ergänzen, Michi, denn wir haben Schalke jetzt im Dezember gehabt, also schon jetzt gegen Ende der Hinserie. Und da bröckelte es auch schon. Also die Partie… Ich würde sagen, wir waren eigentlich lange Zeit das bessere Team in dieser Partie und haben uns dann durch einen sehr unglücklichen Elfmeter und eine gelb-rote Karte, die da in der Entstehung so dann eigentlich auch nicht gegeben werden durfte, haben wir uns da so ein bisschen um den Lohn gebracht. Aber da hatte ich auch schon gedacht, also so richtig wie ein Tabellenführer wirkt das ja alles nicht von Schalke. Und wenn man dann andere Teams sieht, wie jetzt zum letzt Damstadt oder naja, zumindest spielerisch auch Elversberg und wir kommen auch vielleicht noch zu Hannover und deren jetzt aktueller Form, das ist schon was anderes gefühlt, was man da gerade so sieht. Und wie immer, ich will noch einen kleinen statistischen Fun-Fact zu dieser Partie hinterher schieben. Dresden hat genau zweimal auf das Schalker Tor geschossen. Das erkennt uns kennen wir.
Ja, aber da muss man ja sagen, da haben sie Schalke ja fast mit ihren eigenen Waffen geschlagen. Weil eben, also ich erinnere mich eben auch an Spiegel von Schalke, wo du halt einfach wusstest, okay, es reicht halt, wenn die einmal aufs Tor schießen, weil die machen ihr Tor dann, so was, die Klasse ist halt da. Aber danach brauchst du von denen offensiv auch nicht mehr viel erwarten. Und wenn du dann im Unker-Schloss eben ja eigentlich ein Dynamo Dresden hast, was zu dem Zeitpunkt auswärts nichts mehr zu verlieren hat, das muss man ja einfach ganz ehrlich so sagen. Die liegen schon 2-0 zurück und dass sie dann natürlich einfach sagen, okay, wir können jetzt einfach nur probieren und hinten nicht mehr zu viel anbieten. Und da muss ich noch, du darfst sofort ergänzen, Thorsten. Wir haben jetzt über einen Personagel noch nicht so richtig gesprochen, und das ist Musa Silla. Dessen Transfer zu New York City FC ist ja geplatzt. Die Verträge waren quasi schon unterschrieben und dann hat eben New York gesagt, nee, doch lieber Laie. Und hat Schalke natürlich gesagt, wollen wir nicht. Und ich finde, das macht eben, Thorsten, du hast es eben schon mal angesprochen, was ist eigentlich mit den Interna? Also wie ist das Mannschaftsgefüge jetzt? Und da muss ich glaube, also Silla wollte eben nach dem Spiel eigentlich auch nicht sprechen, wollte nicht an die Mikros treten. Und da muss man natürlich sagen, was passiert da denn? Also du holst eben Leute wie J.Co., wie Ljubicic, wie Aoici, Aoici? Ich, es tut mir wirklich leid. Es, ich muss, das dauern noch so zwei Spiele, dann habe ich die Namen auch einigermaßen fehlerfrei drauf. Und das sind eben auch alles Namen, nicht nur die Erfahrung mitbringen, sondern die eben auch Stichwort Erwachtungshaltung mitbringen. Und deshalb gucken wir jetzt anders auch auf Schalke, weil wenn du so eine Transfer-Offensive im Winter fährst, dann gehe ich davon aus, okay, die machen jetzt ausseins Point-to-Ausstieg. Und da ist dann natürlich schwierig, wenn du dann so einen Auftritt dahin legst. Und gleichzeitig wissen nämlich auch die Gegner, okay, also erstmal Schalke muss mal. Und bei Schalke ist jetzt der Druck, weil ich kann mir nämlich auch vorstellen, wenn du als Schalke 04 davon ausgehst, dass du noch einen Transferplus von 7 Millionen machst, plus minus, jetzt mal bei Silla, was glaube ich so im Raum stand. Und der fällt dann weg. Und du hast aber im Prinzip, was du natürlich nicht machen solltest, aber unterschwellig mit eben dieser Einnahmequelle gerechnet, mit der du eigentlich seit dem Sommer rechnest. Weil dieser Silla-Abgang steht ja erst nicht erst seit vorgestern im Raum. Und das scheitert wieder. Ich weiß halt auch nicht, was das... Also, weil wir wissen alle, wie es finanziell um Schalke steht. Ja, wir wissen auch, dass es jetzt bergauf ging. Aber auf Rosen gebettet ist dieser Verein, glaube ich, weiterhin trotzdem nicht. Ich glaube, das können wir alle festhalten. Und auch da steigt dann ja der Druck, weil du eigentlich sagst, okay, sie brauchen dann jedes weitere 2. Liga-Jahr, bringt dich auch in den TV-Einnahmen weiter nach unten. Und natürlich auch generell. Also, die können mir alle nochmal 5x erzählen, wie wenig Elin Dzeko und das Jahr ablösefrei und dies und das. Und der wollte ja auch nicht so viel und bietet sich Schalke an. Aber also, ich glaube, die Gehaltsstruktur bei Schalke 04, da sprechen wir über eine ganz andere Gehaltsstruktur als bei, ich würde mal sagen, 80% der Teams in der 2. Liga. Und der wird schon, also wird schon, glaube ich, noch zu den besser bezahlten Spielern in diesem Kader gehören. In einem Kader, der sowieso mit einem Loris Karius und Co. glaube ich jetzt schon so ein bisschen an Gehalt zahlen muss. Und da ist nämlich, finde ich nämlich, das gar nicht so viel, um auf deinen Punkt zurückzukommen, Thorsten, so ganz weit hergeholt, dass das natürlich auch irgendwann Mannschaftsgefüge zerstören kann. Und das ist eben das, worüber Schalke eben auch über weite Strecken gekommen ist. Also neben den Abschlüssen, die sie eben hatten und die sie genutzt haben und dieser Gewissheit, okay, wenn wir einmal führen, wird es schon schwierig gegen uns. Da war es eben auch das Gefüge. Und wenn du jetzt merkst, es bricht an ein, zwei Stellen durcheinander, da weiß ich nicht, ob die sich nicht brutal verzockt haben.
Das ist auf jeden Fall möglich. Und gerade wo du diesen Punktzüller ansprichst, da bin ich nämlich auch darüber gestolpert, es stand irgendwo dann auch in der Presse, gerade zu dieser Ablöse und den vermeintlich eingeplanten 6 Millionen, dass das alles ja jetzt nicht mehr so schlimm sei, weil man ja andere Sachen eingenommen hat. Und da habe ich mir auch gedacht, wow, vor anderthalb Jahren ging es noch darum, Lizenz kriegt man die und Punktabzüge und jetzt ist es schon wieder egal, ob man die 6 Millionen noch bekommt und nicht. Also da habe ich mich auch gefragt, Leute, habt ihr eigentlich nicht gelernt aus der Vergangenheit, dass das vielleicht alles nach wie vor spitz auf Knopf genäht sein könnte hier? Und da, das hat mich etwas gewundert. Ich wollte aber eben nur noch eine Kleinigkeit ergänzen, weil du mich so schön beim ersten Spiel gefragt hattest, wie der Trainer Thorsten denn mit der Viertermannschaft umgesprungen wäre. Der Imaginäre wohlgemerkt. Und ich würde, wenn ich gegen Schalke spiele als Amateur-Coach hier, ich würde denen den beigeben und sagen, ja, dann mach doch mal. Also ich bin auf die Statistik ja eingegangen. Ich glaube wirklich, Schalke hat ein Problem, wenn sie machen müssen. Wenn die einmal in Führung liegen, dann ist brutal schwer gegen Schalke, glaube ich, dann noch Tore zu erzielen. Darum Respekt, dass Dresden das geschafft hat. Über Dresden haben wir ja auch schon ein bisschen gesprochen. Die kommen ja nun wirklich sehr, sehr gut in die Rückrunde, sind eins der Teams, die sich wirklich sehr stark gewandelt haben, auch durch den ein oder anderen Transfer. Aber ansonsten wäre das immer so die Herangehensweise, weil ich sehe einfach diese spielerischen Schwächen bei Schalke. Vieles war in dieser Partie dann auch individuelle Klasse von Schicko, das muss man einfach so sagen. Und das kann auf Sicht eigentlich nicht gut gehen, wenn du nur über diese Schiene kommst. Das war ja auch mein Kritikpunkt bei Kaiserslautern mit Brettaien, dass sie halt auch zu sehr eigentlich auf diesen einen wirklich in überrahmender Form sich befindenden Stürmer gesetzt haben, aber spielerisch das Ganze eigentlich, also die Ansprüche nicht so unterfüttern konnte. Und das sehe ich bei Schalke eben auch. Also du musst nicht die spielerisch beste Mannschaft sein, um aufzusteigen, um vielleicht das zu sagen. Ich meine, gucken wir auf Heidenheim oder so was, die sind auch vor allem durch Intensität damals aufgestiegen hatten, auch einen Individualisten mit Kleindienst in der 2. Liga dann, der sehr viel in der Saison getroffen hat. Also das kann schon ein Weg sein, aber come on, Tabellenletzter bei Ballbesitz und Passquote, das ist nicht aufstiegsreif. So was, auf Sicht.
Ja, also ich glaube, das ist durchaus berechtigte Kritik. Und wenn wir mal so ein bisschen auf den Spielplan gucken von Schalke 04, ich würde jetzt mal so ein paar Spiele mehr mit reinnehmen, als nur die nächsten zwei. Man spielt jetzt auswärts Sonntag bei Holstein Kiel. Auch nicht das beste Team momentan, aber gehe ich auch mal von aus, dass die eben sagen, ja, Schalke, dann nimm doch mal den Ball. Dann gut zu Hause gegen Magdeburg, da kann man schon davon ausgehen, dass eben die Magdeburger den Ball haben werden. Und dann aber wird auswärts und Amina Bielefeld. Und das sind zwei Teams, wo wir, glaube ich, sehr sicher sein können, die wollen den Ball nicht haben. Gerade in der aktuellen Situation und auch einfach von dem, was sie spielen wollen. Michi, correct me if I'm wrong, aber da würde ich jetzt mal sagen, Führt möchte jetzt gegen Schalke nicht den Ball haben.
Wir wollen in allen Phasen des Spiels gut sein, würde Heiko Vogel wahrscheinlich jetzt sagen.
Okay, das war sehr diplomatisch von dir, aber gut. Also und danach hast du eben Spiele gegen Hannover und Darmstadt. Und da bin ich schon, also du hast einmal diese Spiele, wo man sagt so, okay, das ist irgendwie Kiel, ist unten reingerutscht. Das ist so ein Team, das befindet sich gerade im Abstiegskampf und oder wieder, was es vielleicht dachte, dass sie das schon eigentlich da einen Haken hintergemacht haben und dachten ja, erstmal konsolidieren und dann gucken wir weiter. Magdeburg, haben wir drüber gesprochen, Führt und Bielefeld auch, aber alles Teams von da unten, eben wie Dynamo Dresden. Und da bin ich, also ich gehe jetzt nicht davon aus, dass jedes dieser Teams eins zu eins das machen wird, was Dresden gemacht hat und die wollen sicherlich auch nicht 2-0 in den Rückstand geraten, weil das kannst du natürlich nicht immer replizieren. Aber du siehst eben, wo ist Schalke angreifbar. Und ich glaube, das sind Punkte, glaube dir Marc und ich eben auch im Hin-Rücken-Rückblick so ein bisschen angesprochen. Thorsten, ich erinnere mich daran, dass wir da, glaube ich, auch in eurer Rückrundenvorschau so ein bisschen drüber gesprochen haben. Wenn du eben Punkte findest, Schalke da so ein bisschen ihr Spiel wegzunehmen, dann bin ich eben gespannt, wie das wird. Und da muss man Stand jetzt sagen, gut, findet Schalke da eben zeitnah eine Antwort drauf. Ich meine, sie sind immer noch auf Platz 2, aber man muss ja sagen, sie haben jetzt eben Darmstadt an sich vorbeiziehen lassen und das eigentlich ehrlich gesagt komplett unnötig, weil man eben auf einmal anfällig ist, wo man es vorher nicht war und eben da in ein, zwei Punkten vielleicht auch einfach Unruhe reingebracht hat, was nicht sein müsste. Gut, ich glaube, da können wir gespannt sein, wie es weitergeht. Ich würde aber sagen, wir gucken auf den nächsten Verein und das ist Aminia Bielefeld. Platz 11, 24 Punkte, ich sage gleich was dazu, 33 zu 30 Tore, 6 Siege, 6 Unentschieden und 9 Niederlagen. Vorm Tabelle Platz 10 und das hat vor allem dem Sieg gegen Braunschweig gestern, also dem zu verdanken. Das war der erste Sieg seit dem 8.11. gegen Karlsruhe. Es ist also auf den Tag drei Jahre, drei Jahre wäre schlimm, drei Monate her gewesen, dass man zuletzt drei Punkte einfahren konnte. Und deshalb hatten wir das vorher schon so ein bisschen reingezogen, weil man muss eben sagen, da waren zuletzt, also man hat eben ein Sieg, jetzt zwei Unentschieden, eine Niederlage in 2026 geholt. Die Unentschieden gegen Kiel und Dresden, nachdem man da jeweils zurückgelegen hat. Also so, man könnte sagen, Punkte für die Moral, aber eben auch gegen Braunschweig hat man zurückgelegen und dann am Ende das Spiel noch 3-2 zu gewinnen. Also es war ein…
Gegen wen hat man verloren? Das hatte ich gar nicht auf dem Schirm. Gegen wen hat Bielefeld verloren?
Rot-Weiß, naja, ganz, ganz unheimlich. Ich hatte eine wunderbare Laune. Es war natürlich gegen…
Vor dem Spiel warst du sehr gut gelaufen.
Ja, ja, ja. Da hatte ich auch gerade meine Bachelorarbeit abgegeben. Ich konnte gar nichts mehr treffen.
So nämlich.
Und dann kamen diese 90 Minuten. Na ja, ich sag noch zwei Sachen. Dann frag ich euch erstmal eure Meinung zu dem DSC. Im Winter sind gekommen Maxi Bauer, Janik Rochelt, Simi Telalovic und Robin Knoche die ersten drei Perleihe. Knoche ablösefrei von Nürnberg, der war der Ersatz für Joel Felix, der sich… der an der Schulter operiert werden muss, nachdem er sich eben kurzfristig im Spiel gegen Kiel verletzt hatte, da konnte man dann noch schnell reagieren. Dafür Julian Kania, Perleihe nach Osnabrück, Lukas Kunze– ja, es gibt immer noch zwei davon– zu Rostock und Vincent Okensey zu Aue Norby und Michi Lasz-Leye. Die wurden tatsächlich im Winter nach einem halben Jahr beendet. Und man ist das einzige Team in der unteren Tabellenhälfte mit einem positiven Torverhältnis. Das hat man sich vor allem zu Beginn der Saison so ein bisschen erarbeitet. Gegen Wenwohl.
Jetzt kommt die Rache. Ich sehe es schon.
So, musste sein. Michi, ich frage dich mal, dass als Erstes, weil du ja so schön angesprochen hast, dass man ja unter anderem bei Bielefeld gewonnen hat. Und wir sehen uns ja auch in zwei Wochen bei der Partie Fürth gegen Bielefeld. Was ist denn dein genereller Eindruck von Bielefeld in 2026?
Ja, es ist ganz krass eigentlich zu sehen. Ich habe das nicht mehr so präsent gehabt, dass die Armenia tatsächlich ja drei Monate ohne Sieg war. Und so, wenn man den Fürth sich umgehört hat, da war das so, Bielefeld, die Transferphase, was die alles für Spieler holen, die hätten alle Fürth doch auch gut getan. Und dann so, also ein Stürmer und Maxi Bauer ist ja ein Fürther Eigengewächs. Warum kommt denn der nicht nach Fürth? Und dann schaut man ja vor diesem Spieltag zwei Punkte aus drei Spielen. Das vergisst man dann immer ein bisschen. Aber ich glaube tatsächlich, also erstmal individuelle Qualität im Winter ist gestiegen bei Arminia Bielefeld. Klar muss ich auch bei Knochen wieder ein bisschen eingrooven, aber als trotzdem jemand, der eine internationale Erfahrung hat und beim Club war er sehr, sagen wir mal, umstritten. Das kann ich sagen aus den vielen Gesprächen mit meinen Kollegen hier in Nürnberg. Aber trotzdem ist es ja ein Verteidiger in der zweiten Liga bei einer Mannschaft, die unten mit drin steht, der erst noch von seiner Erfahrung und auch von seiner Führungsqualität einer Mannschaft extrem gut tun kann. Maxi Bauer hat auch schon einige Erfahrungen, also das kann schon ein Innenverteidiger-Duo sein, das erstmal im reinen Verteidigen schon einer Mannschaft gut tut. Ich habe ein bisschen Sorge, was so die Geschwindigkeit angeht. Also wenn man mal höher steht mit diesen beiden Innenverteidigern, das könnte gefährlich werden. Ich sehe das auch beim Spiel gegen Fürth vielleicht. Wenn die Fürth da wirklich nur noch auf Kontern und Nadelstiche setzen, mit schnellen Offensivspielern setzen, könnte da vielleicht der wunde Punkt der Arminia sein. Aber trotzdem, du hast es angesprochen, dieses positive Torverhältnis als Thorsten, einer von euch beiden, ich bin schon durcheinander.
Ich weiß nicht.
Aber das positive Torverhältnis da unten drin, das ist schon krass, weil man halt sieht, die Arminia hat 24 Punkte und ist damit halt vor zwei oder drei anderen Mannschaften. Und am Ende wird es wahrscheinlich vielleicht sogar aufs Torverhältnis ankommen, wenn das weiterhin zu eng bleibt. Und dann kann man damit halt mal faktisch einen Punkt mehr. Ja, also ich sage bei Fürth immer, muss man immer sagen, wenn eben jemand fragt, ja es sind drei Punkte plus Torverhältnis mehr, bei der Arminia ist es halt immer das positive. Also ich sehe, ich blicke positiv auf die Arminia. Andererseits hat man jetzt mal einen Sprung gemacht von 16 auf 11, das zeigt aber auch, wie eng es da unten ist. Also Platz 11 kann auch trügerisch sein, weil man kann dann in zwei Wochen gegen Fürth spielen. Also dann kann das auch wieder alles sehr eng zusammenrücken. Also trotzdem bin ich insgesamt– Eva, das kann dich vielleicht beruhigen als Außenstehender– relativ positiv, dass es bei der Arminia vielleicht auch noch gut ausgeht, weil ich andere Mannschaften von der Form und individuell auch schlechter sehe.
Das beruhigt mich erstmal. Thorsten, wir hatten so ein bisschen rund um das Spiel ja davor sowieso geschnackt, aber auch danach, weil ich eigentlich gesagt habe, ganz ehrlich, also beide Mannschaften haben sich in dem Spiel ehrlich gesagt nicht mit Ruhm bekleckert. Also 0-0 kann das am Ende des Tages auch ausgehen. Die Fortuna dann natürlich einfach, ja auch mit der individuellen Qualität. Am Ende des Tages, die eben dann wahrscheinlich auch in View verdient, den Sieg holen. Wir haben ja auch schon viel gemeinsam generell über Bielefeld gesprochen und ich weiß noch, ich habe zu euch gesagt, ich glaube schon, dass es am Ende reicht. Man wird nicht die gleichen Punkte holen wie in der Hinrunde. Davon gehe ich nicht aus, also dass es quasi Copycat-mäßig wird. Ja, jetzt haben wir irgendwie so ein paar Spiele da. Jetzt hast du zwar gegen Braunschock, gegen eine Mannschaft gewonnen, gegen die hast du in der Hinrunde nicht gewonnen, gleichzeitig aber gegen Kiel nicht gewonnen und gegen Düsseldorf auch noch verloren. Bist du weiterhin einigermaßen positiv auch gestimmt bei der M1A?
Ja, das bin ich. Also ich bin da auch ganz bei Michi. Ich finde tatsächlich, ihr habt euch relativ sinnvoll im Winter verstärkt. Ehrlicherweise, und da wird mich jetzt Anna aus dem All-Star-Team wahrscheinlich auch noch zurechtweisen, wenn ich das jetzt tue, aber gerade in dieser Partie jetzt im Vergleich zu der Transferpolitik von Eintracht Braunschweig, finde ich, dass bei euch– also ich kann da mehr Konzept erkennen. Ihr habt eindeutig identifiziert, uns fehlt ein bisschen Zweitligarefahrung als Mannschaft. Und die habt ihr hinzugefügt. Alle Spieler haben Zweitligarefahrungen, die ihr geholt habt. Für die ist die Liga nicht neu. Sie rochelt ja sogar mit herausragenden Leistungen in der Vergangenheit. Tlalowet hat zumindest letztes Jahr bei Ulm ganz gut performt, jetzt bei Nürnberg natürlich nicht. Das ist vielleicht auch der Transfer, wo ich am ehesten auch noch ein bisschen Skepsis habe. Aber Knoche und Bauer, der– na ja, okay– war bei Kaiserslautern, ich würde ihn jetzt nicht als herausragend letztes Jahr da bezeichnen, sind zumindest mal eine 2. Liga erfahrene Innenverteidigung. Das ist jetzt schon mal eine ganz gute Voraussetzung und gefühlt, das hatte Michael jetzt ja zu Robin Knoche auch gesagt, ist schon ein anderes Kaliber jetzt da hinten drin in der Verteidigung. Darum, ich kann das Konzept dahinter verstehen und dazu kommt natürlich so ein bisschen so die Ruhe. Also wenn ich dann nur ganz kurz auf Braunschweig blicke, da hat man halt Spieler geholt, die irgendwann mal irgendwie vielleicht auch mal drei Einsätze in der 2. Liga hatten, aber nirgendwo so richtig Stammspieler waren oder so. Das ist nämlich zum Beispiel ein Unterschied. Telolovic war zumindest vorher oder Rochelt bei ihren vorherigen Stationen, also nicht den direkten, sondern den vorvorletzten sozusagen, waren irgendwie über längere Zeit mal Stammspieler. Leute wie Opoku oder Alidou, die waren das eigentlich nicht. Auch Ranos hat sich in Lautern nicht durchgesteckt. Wir haben sehr auffällig das Gefühl, dass alle neu zugängende Lautern Vergangenheit haben, genau wie Benjamin Kessel, der sportliche Leiter. Man hat ja einmal bei Braunschweig so komplett die Offensive ausgetauscht. Klar, auch gezwungenermaßen mit Christian Conté. Ich weiß noch nicht, ob wir kurz die Sven-Köhler-Geschichte erwähnen wollen. Aber ich finde, ihr fandt die Transferpolitik bei euch, und das war eigentlich mein Punkt, den ich jetzt vielleicht etwas zu ausführlich gemacht habe, dass es für mich konzeptionell total nachvollziehbar ist. Und das in der Kombination, mein Eindruck von außen ist, ihr habt einen Trainer, der bei euch funktioniert und eigentlich auch ein Umfeld, dass er alles zu wertschätzen weiß und nicht die Nerven verliert, wie jetzt vielleicht bei anderen Vereinen das schon der Fall sein könnte. Und diese Ruhe mit– wir haben jetzt eigentlich auch Qualität dazugeholt, und das hatten wir in der Analyse bei uns, nämlich tatsächlich ja auch zu euch gesagt. Ihr seid weder offensiv noch defensiv wirklich schlecht, wenn man sich rein mal die Zahlenausbeute anschaut. Ihr habt ordentlich Tore geschossen und ihr habt auch nicht so viele kassiert. Das ist schon mal sehr viel wert, kann ich euch sagen. Darum sehe ich Arminia natürlich nicht gerettet. Ihr müsst genauso punkten und wenn jetzt eine Krise kommt, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, dann kann das natürlich auch da eng werden. Aber jetzt hat man ja diesen Sieg geholt, der war bitter nötig, glaube ich auch für die Köpfe. Und ich glaube, jetzt kann das auch wieder ein bisschen besser laufen. Jetzt sind natürlich spannende Partien, zweimal auswärts. Ihr seid gefühlt auswärts nicht so stark.
Sieben Punkte haben wir geholt. Der letzte Sieg war das erste Auswärtsspiel in Kiel.
Also ich fand euch in der Partie bei uns in Düsseldorf nicht sehr torgefährlich. Wir stehen zwar als Fortuna inzwischen auch einfach defensiv besser. Das haben wir auch gestern in Karlsruhe gezeigt. Das zeigen wir noch in Kaiserslautern. Da habt ihr euch wenig Torschancen erspielen lassen, sodass ich schon der Meinung war, nein, ein Tor hätte Amine eigentlich nicht verdient gehabt, auch weil er zwar immer auf die Latte geschossen hat. Aber naja. Und wir hatten dann noch ein paar Torschancen mehr, dass man sagen konnte, ja auch wenn es ein Lucky Punch war, durch individuelle Klasse von einem Stürmer wie Itten, wahrscheinlich war es schon halbwegs fair. Und da habe ich schon gedacht, oh, das könnte schwer werden für Bielefeld, weil er halt so wenig nach vorne ging. Aber das haben mir jetzt die anderen Spiele ja schon eher gezeigt. Und ich glaube, es war sehr wichtig, dass ihr in Dresden nicht verloren habt. Ich glaube, das war auch so jetzt der Punkt, den ihr so mitgenommen habt und vielleicht auch vorher, dass ihr gegen Kiel, wo ja die erste Halbzeit ziemlich unsehend war, dass ihr da auch zurückgekommen seid und ausgeglichen habt. Also ich glaube, es gab in den Spielen vorher so ein paar psychologische Momente, die die Mannschaft jetzt schon in die richtige Richtung gebracht haben. Ja, und gegen Braunschweig jetzt war auch ein– also ich habe das Spiel nicht gesehen, ich war ja selber im Stadion in Karlsruhe gestern, ich habe jetzt nur die Highlights gesehen, ein paar schöne Tore dabei. Aber ich hatte so den Eindruck, ja, beide Mannschaften haben schon gemerkt, worum es in diesem Spiel ging. Und die Tatsache, dass ihr es am Ende vor euch entschieden habt, ich glaube, das kann euch so helfen, wie es Braunschweck möglicherweise in den nächsten Wochen ein bisschen zu schaffen machen könnte. Auch wenn die Woche davor gegen K2 gewonnen hat.
Ganz kurze Ergänzung, Michi, dann darfst du. Ich muss da auch sagen, ich finde es sehr gut, wie das von der Mannschaft, vom Trainer auch aufgefangen wird. Also da wurde auch selber klar gesagt, ja, es war jetzt ein Sechs-Punkte-Spiel und das haben wir gewonnen. Und es folgen jetzt eben noch zwei weitere gegen Magdeburg und gegen Fürth, eben beides Auswärtsspiele. Und gleichzeitig eben auch sagt, ja, also Blick auf die Tabelle bringt gerade gar nichts. Klar fühlt sich es besser an, auf Platz 11 zu stehen nach dem Wochenende, als auf Platz 16, einfach für den Kopf. Aber den auch allen bewusst, also wir wissen ja auch selber, wo wir da gelandet sind. Und ich glaube, man muss wirklich sagen, dieser psychologische Faktor, der wird noch richtig wichtig. Und ich glaube auch, also mich, ich fand das so interessant, dann darfst du sofort. Du hast eben angesprochen bei FÜHRT, eben dieses, was vor diesem Spiel alles stattgefunden hat. Und eigentlich war es ja so ein Schulterschluss. Und von der Fanszene gab es eben vor dem Spiel gestern, gab es vor der Osttribüne, also ausnahmsweise mal eben nicht vor der Süd-, sondern vor der Osttribüne, das, was man als Spieler als Erstes sieht, wenn man eben aus dem Gang kommt, aus dem Kabinentrakt kommt. Vor der Ost stand, glaube ich, mit Kraft und Mut zum Ziel. Wir stehen hinter euch da und da wurde auch nochmal gepusht. Und eben auch nach dem 2-1 ging der Supporter irgendwie weiter. Und du hattest auch das Gefühl, da ist irgendwie was drin. Weil das macht ja auch was mit den Fans, zu wissen, okay, wir sind jetzt noch nicht komplett abgeschrieben nach einem Rückstand. Schön war es nicht. Sagt man trotzdem, wenn du dann irgendwie dabei zugucken kannst, wie so ein Frenkart da einfach mal durchläuft ohne jegliche Gegenwehr. Aber ich hatte wirklich so ein bisschen das Gefühl, es lag irgendwie so ein bisschen was in der Luft und es lag wirklich auch so ein bisschen über dem Stadion, so ein bisschen dieser Endspiel-Vibe, so ein bisschen zu wissen, okay, wir gehen jetzt 1-1 gegen Dresden. Da hat man schon ein gutes Spiel gerade in der zweiten Halbzeit gezeigt. Fast vielleicht so mit der zweiten Halbzeit, würde ich fast sagen, von dem, was ich gesehen habe, mit so eins der besten Auswärtsspiele diese Saison, was natürlich auch viel über die Mannschaft aussagt, aber trotzdem. Und dann jetzt eben da zurückzukommen und zu sagen, Hauptsache, wir verlieren erst mal diese Spiele nicht, gegen diese vier wirklich direkten Konkurrenten da unten drin. Und ich glaube, das macht ganz, ganz viel mit der Psyche. Ich habe gleich noch einen Punkt, aber erst auf Michi.
Ich wollte noch einen Namen einwerfen, der noch gar nicht viel. Robert Ulltrickis. Weil wir hatten ja vorhin auch Spieler, die vielleicht keine Winterzugänge sind, aber ja eigentlich schon Winterzugänge sind. Ist ja auch lange ausgefallen im Kreuzbandriss. Ich habe gerade noch mal geschaut, das war sein viertes Spiel jetzt ja. In vier Spielen jetzt die zwei Tore in diesem und noch mal ein Assist. Also drei Scorer in vier Spielen. Ist jetzt nicht so schlecht, vor allem, wenn man auf der Bank dann ja einen Godowski hat, der ja auch schon acht Tore hat. Also und einen Telalovic, den man ja auch noch hat. Und der in Ulm, wie du schon sagtest, er schon angedeutet hat, dass er in der zweiten Liga auch Tore schießen kann. Also eigentlich hat man für den Abstiegskampf jetzt eine ganz gute Offensive noch dazu mit Rochelt, wenn er funktioniert, und mit Wörl, der ja eigentlich auch jetzt in dem Spiel auch mit seinem Tor gezeigt hat, was er kann, als insofern das ist meine These noch mal.
Kai Wölthor war es.
Ich grätsche noch kurz rein, bevor du sozusagen Bielefeld abschließt. Ich finde, also Ulricis wollte ich eigentlich auch noch erwähnt haben. Der Lette, Ulricis der Lette, das finde ich, das passt wie Hermann der Trabusker. Also eigentlich, das ist doch Arminia Bielefeld.
Er ist und war sauber.
Ja, genau.
Ich wollte dich nicht unterbrechen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du noch was hast.
Nein, nein, alles gut. Ich wollte ihn nur einwerfen und zur Ehre gelangen lassen, weil wenn er hier zwei Tore macht bei einem 3 zu 2 Sieg, dann sollte er auch einmal zumindest angesprochen sein. Ich bin sehr gespannt, den live zu sehen. Den habe ich bislang nicht sehen können live im Stadion.
Es ist, also sagen wir mal so, er hätte noch ein bisschen mehr Ballbehandlung am Fuß, dann würde er in den englischen Premier League Club ihn als Wollte-Mal-Ersatz vielleicht im Sommer kaufen. Die gleiche Statue hat er, aber das sind auch die größten Vergleiche. Ich glaube, man muss einfach sagen, wenn man auch merkt, gestern Ulrikus wurde zum Beispiel von Tömantwerker, da er selber erst seit Sommer da ist oder so, und auch explizit von Marius Wörl und vom Trainer nochmal gelobt. Marius Wörl hat gesagt, wenn man weiß, wie viel er gearbeitet hat an seinem Comeback. Und man muss ja auch sagen, also Ulrikus war ein Winterneuzugang vor einem Jahr. Und hat sich dann, glaube ich, im vierten oder fünften Spiel den Kreuzbandriss zugezogen. Also der hat zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht lange gespielt. Und das ist ehrlich gesagt ein wahnsinnig großes Kompliment an die Mannschaft, dass sie den eben auch so integriert haben und dass er Bock hatte, auch einfach mit dieser Mannschaft wieder zu spielen. Wurde gestern von der Mannschaft eben auch vor die Süd geschubst, so. Und hat dann aber gesagt, nee, nee, das sind schon wir alle so. Und das tut einfach gut. Und auch für Marius Wörl freut es mich. Der hatte auch einen Grinsen einfach im Gesicht, weil der eben auch keine leichte Zeit hatte, gerade weil er ja auch mit Erwartungen nach Bielefeld kam. Dieser hohen Ablösesumme, die man ja im Endeffekt für ihn an Hannover bezahlt hat. Und da weiten waren alle so, ja, das war so ein bisschen der Pokal Marius, der jetzt sowieso besser in 2026 reingekommen ist. Der hat selber auch gesagt, ich brauchte diese Winterpause, um den Kopf ein bisschen freizukriegen. Es waren dann doch alles auch relativ viel in diesem Jahr. Muss man einfach sagen, für ihn im Pokalfinale mit Bielefeld gestanden, dann diese ganze Wechselpose rund um Hannover. Und dann kommt er mit den Erwartungen nach Bielefeld. Das fand ich auch sehr ehrlich. Und ich glaube, und ihr habt es mit der Abwehr abgesprochen, das kann natürlich auch in die falsche Richtung gehen, was mit Maxi Großer und Leon Schneider, jetzt eben zwei Ausstiegspokal-Helden, whatever, das so ein bisschen verdrängt von ihren Posten. Leon Schneider halt einfach mit unglücklichen Auftritten zuletzt, aber vielleicht auch gut, da mal den Druck ein bisschen runterzunehmen. Und im Endeffekt, ja, bedeutet, also, ist ja einfach gut, jetzt die Rotation drin zu haben. Und ich glaube gerade, du hast eben mit Rochelt und Hilaro zwei Leute geholt, die eben, ja, denen das Selbstbewusstsein ein bisschen flöten ging zuletzt. Und da merkst du aber auch, also gerade bei Rochelt, der den Assist zum 1-0 zum Beispiel auch gibt, da ist auf jeden Fall, ich glaube, das klingt immer so merkwürdig, aber wenn gerade ein Team das schafft, in dieser Phase dann doch Leute einzubeziehen und vielleicht wieder auf eine neue Höhe zu bringen, dann ist das, glaube ich, Aminja, weil das haben sie damals mit Grotowski auch gemacht. Also ich plädiere trotzdem dafür. Gali grü an Bielefeld-Fans. Gibt Rochelt doch trotzdem vielleicht noch drei Spiele Zeit. Winterneuzugänge ist so ein Ding, nur weil das bei uns in letzter Zeit, auch wenn der Maxi Bauer enorm gut funktioniert hat, dass der schon so eingebunden ist. Es ist ein Winterneuzugang. Chillt bitte alle mal. Gut, ich würde sagen, das beenden wir auch. Diesen ostwestchilischen Verein, ich habe jetzt oft genug gesagt, was die nächsten Spiele sind. Wie gesagt, wir schauen mal, wo das weiter hingeht. Trotzdem kann man glaube ich sagen, die Probleme, die waren trotzdem ersichtlich gerade vorm Thor. Und jetzt schauen wir auf einen Verein, wo ihr vielleicht auch denkt, hä, warum hat der das jetzt hier reingeschafft? Schlechte Performance. Das ist der SC Paderborn, auch hier Platz 3, I know. 39 Punkte, 33 zu 24 Tore, 12 Siege, 3 Unentschieden und 6 Niederlagen. Vorm Tabelle in den letzten 5 Spielen Platz 8. Das klingt nicht so schlecht, aber man hatte eben 2 Siege, 2 Niederlagen. Man weiß gerade irgendwie nicht so ganz, was man mit dem SCP bekommt. Ja, sie haben am Wochenende 2 zu 1 gegen Nürnberg gewonnen, aber man muss sozusagen im zweiten Spiel hier eben auch in einer Überzahl-Situation, was ihn bestimmt auch ein bisschen in die Karten gespielt hat. Michi, ich starte nochmal kurz bei dir. Generell haben wir natürlich überlegt, warum nehmen wir Pada Born überhaupt hier rein. Findest du denn, also liebe Grüße an Kevin auch, weil der nämlich uns selber, glaube ich, so ein bisschen Pada Born auf die Karte geschrieben hat. Siehst du beim SCP gerade Probleme?
Jetzt wieder weniger nach diesem Spiel, weil es einfach tabellarisch wieder besser ausschaut, weil man zum ersten Mal in der Rückrunde gewonnen hat. Davor ja nur 3 aus 3, also 3 Punkte aus 3 Spielen. Jetzt wieder dieser Sieg wichtig, weil man das oben wieder rangeklettert. Auch, also ich habe wieder meinen Crush getroffen, Laurin Koder, wenn der in Form ist, das ist schon, also wirklich, als ich den live gesehen habe in diesem Spiel auch wieder, und dann, also, er ist einfach ein zu guter Spieler für die Liga. Aber er ist halt als rechter Schiedensspieler, auch der Topscorer des SCP, deswegen kann man das wieder positiv wie negativ sehen. Ich hatte irgendwo auf den Take gelesen, die Offensive, die da am Wochenende, also die Angriffsreihe, ist keine, der ist ein Zweitliga-Aufsteiger, diesen Take kann man auch sehen mit Tiggers und Klaas. Die haben jetzt alle, ich glaube, 3 und 4 Tore, die beiden. Also jetzt weniger als der rechte Schiedensspieler, der ja dann teilweise auch im Verteidigen noch mehr eingebunden ist. Aber vielleicht ist Laurin Kurta auch nicht der Maßstab, weil er halt einfach so extrem gut ist. Aber insgesamt ist es doch trotzdem jetzt stabil. Man hat halt mal eine kleine schwäche Phase gehabt, aber man ist da oben voll mit dabei. Man kann Spiele eigentlich immer eng gestalten. Man sinkt nie unter ein gewisses Level-Up als es ist Cepada Born. Insofern gibt es da viele Zutaten, die dafür sprechen, dass man auch wieder lange mit oben dabei bleibt. Man ist hier auch mittendrin. Man wird jetzt auch mit einer Niederlage da wieder rausrutschen. Insofern, klar, man kann sie mit reinnehmen, weil der Rückrundenauftakt nicht so gut war. Aber sie haben jetzt eben gewonnen gegen den 1. FC Nürnberg. Ja, in Überzahl, wir wissen aber auch alle, dass Überzahl nicht immer das Leichteste ist. Das zu spielen. Leidvolle Erinnerungen habe ich ja auch an diesen Vereinen, den ich enger verfolge in einigen Spielen. Aber ich glaube, die bleiben da sehr, sehr lange oben dabei. Und wir haben sie jetzt halt mit reingenommen, damit wir sie auch dabei haben. Aber in der nächsten Folge sind sie nicht mehr unter den Teams, um die man sich Sorgen machen muss.
Ja. Thorsten, du hast Paderborn ja gesehen. Und vor allem, weil sie eins ihrer Spiele gegen die Fortuna verloren haben. Hier muss man sagen, da war die Fortuna in Überzahl. Das gehört natürlich auch zur Geschichte dazu. Obwohl man da sagen muss, also die letzten, ich glaube, 18 Minuten oder so, gab es da eine gelb-rote Karte. Und wie würdest du denn auf den SCP gucken?
Ja, ich finde, man kann allerdings, wenn wir über Probleme bei Paderborn sprechen, dann kann man sie in den letzten zwei Spielen zumindest jetzt mal exemplarisch ganz gut sehen. Es ist so die Konstanz über 90 Minuten, die fehlt ein bisschen. Wenn man jetzt das Spiel gegen Nürnberg anschaut, ich fand, sie haben sehr stark begonnen und gehen auch ehrlicherweise vollkommen zurecht mit 2 zu 0 in Führung in der Partie. Dann kommt die rote Karte gegen Lubach, wo ich übrigens immer noch der Meinung bin, dass sie ein bisschen hart ist. Ich weiß, die Spieler haben selber, also ich glaube, Jan Reichert, der Torwart von Nürnberg, meinte hinterher, dass der Stutzen von Tigges kaputt sei und darum ging das Ding wohl in Ordnung. Lubach war selbst ein bisschen anderer Meinung. Ich fand jetzt auch, dass der Schuh nicht so hoch war. Müssen aber jetzt auch nicht zu sehr darüber diskutieren. Kann man aber wahrscheinlich ein bisschen. Aber auf jeden Fall bis zu dieser roten Karte lief es eigentlich ganz gut. Danach eigentlich auch noch. Und aus irgendeinem Grund wurden sie aber dann super nervös, als der Lokoschwili das 2-1 gemacht hat. Dann klappte kaum noch was und dann gab es sogar noch eine Riesenschance von Grimaidi dann später fast zum Ausgleich in Unterzahl für den Club. Und da habe ich mich ein bisschen an die Partie bei uns erinnert gefühlt. Da ist nämlich Paderborn nach fünf Minuten in Führung gegangen, nach einer Ecke durch ihren Winterneuzugang, Kennedy Ogpalla. Also so ein bisschen das Stürmerproblem, habt ihr angesprochen, haben sie, glaube ich, versucht damit zu adressieren. Der hatte immerhin sieben Tore jetzt in 18 Hinrundenspiele in Mannheim in der 3. Liga geschossen, gab auch ein bisschen Knatsch. Kann man alles nachlesen mit Kündigungen und sonst was, aber man hat sich geeinigt am Ende auf eine Ablöse und dann war das gut. Und da haben sie also früher diese Führung gemacht und sind dann aber doch recht schnell in so einen Verwaltungsmodus übergegangen, wo ich schon das Gefühl hatte, naja, ich wollte nicht irgendwie mal versuchen, 2 zu 0 zu machen, denn ja, unsere Offensive ist nicht gerade die Angst- und Schreckenverbreitende in der Liga, aber wenn man halt dann so passiv spielt und das wurde in der zweiten Halbzeit noch viel, viel passiver, da muss man halt sich nicht wundern, wenn man dann auch die Gegentore entsprechend kassiert. Und das war so ein bisschen, hat mich das erinnert nach dem 2 zu 1 gegen Nürnberg. Da wurden sie auch auf einmal so ein bisschen passiv. Und ich glaube, das ist so, wenn wir über Probleme bei Pallor und Sprechen und es ist schon Jammern auf hohem Niveau, da sind wir uns glaube ich alle einig, dann, dass sie halt es schaffen müssen, mal 90 Minuten das am Stück hinzubekommen. Sie haben es ja jetzt sogar ohne ihren Trainer geschafft. Der hatte nämlich seine vierte Gelbe in Düsseldorf gesehen. Das war insofern ganz lustig. Die Szene wurde im Kicker-Ticker so beschrieben. Es gab eine Szene, die nach einer Notbremse aussah, gegen Hansen und es ging also um die Frage beim VAR-Check, ist es eine Notbremse oder nicht. Und der Kicker-Ticker schrieb, Kettemann regt sich darüber auf, dass Hansen kein Rot bekommt. Was ich sehr schön fand, die Idee, dass der Trainer möchte, dass sein eigener Spieler vom Platz gestellt wird. Den Schreibfehler haben sie dann später korrigiert. Und dazu dann noch eine andere schöne Formulierung, die ich bei Sky gehört habe. Er war VIP-Wiedervillen.
Klingt wie so nach einer RTL2-Reality-TV-Sendung, ehrlich gesagt. Michi Ergenske.
Genau, das stimmt. Und ganz kurz noch, letzter Punkt. Der ist auch wieder etwas ernst gemeintere. Und auch hier der große Standortvorteil, es herrscht einfach Ruhe. Ich habe gerade die Aupalla-Geschichte im Winter genannt. Bei anderen Vereinen stellt man sich vor, das wäre bei Schalke gewesen, was da in der Presse gewesen wäre, mit der Nummer. Aber auch jetzt der Abgang von Luis Engelns, der ja auch, glaube ich, nicht ganz geräuschlos intern ablief. Es gibt auch ein sehr, sehr schönes Anleihen. Inzwischen gibt es das nicht mehr Social-Media-Video, wo er frei und offen heraus, ohne Formulierungshilfe, mal seine Gefühlswelt für den Wechsel nach Hoffenheim noch mal zum Ausdruck bringt. Da hätte Papa Daniel Fakir vielleicht noch ein bisschen helfen können. Ich will damit also nur sagen, das sind so zwei Beispiele, dass es da zwar hinter den Kulissen auch so ein bisschen, naja kracht es wirklich zu viel, aber so ein bisschen knistert, sagen wir es mal so. Es aber eben so wenig ein Thema nach außen hin ist, dass man eben trotzdem weiter einfach in Ruhe arbeiten kann. Und das ist eben, das haben wir heute schon mal bei Darmstadt herausgehoben, das ist ein Vorteil.
Ich wollte nur noch einwenden, also Luis Engels hätte ich auch gerne eingebracht, aber dass man halt einen Spieler aus dem eigenen Nachwuchs für 3 Millionen Euro jetzt wieder verkauft hat. Also ja, ein bisschen Theater, aber es klingelt halt auch in der Kasse. Und Paderborn ist ja dafür bekannt, Spieler zu entwickeln und weiter zu entwickeln. Das machen sie so gut wie kein anderer. Laurin Kurth, das ist ein anderes Beispiel, den ich gerade genannt habe. Der Kamal aus der Regionalliga, das machen sie auch gerne. Aber jetzt hat man halt ein Eigengewächs für 3 Millionen Euro verkauft, also der finanzielle Invest. Klar, es gibt ein Invest ins NLZ, aber man hat keine Ablöse für diesen Spieler oder ähnliches bezahlt. Insofern, das wird ihnen ja auch wieder weitere Spielräume geben für die nächste Saison, falls es nicht klappt. Und so schaffen sie es halt jedes Jahr wieder, sich da oben festzusetzen, sich weiter zu stabilisieren, sich finanziell auch zu entwickeln. Insofern, ja, das wollte ich nur noch einbringen und Thorsten hat es mir vorweggenommen.
Frech. Ich habe tatsächlich einen Punkt zum SCP. Also, das ist jetzt kein Drohtszenario oder sonst was, aber ich fand das irgendwie so ein bisschen, ja fast, schon ein bisschen metaphorisch für die letzten Saisons, weil wir hatten so oft den SCP, dass er wieder mal am Aufstieg gekratzt hat. Und es war dann immer so die Endphase der Saison, wo man selber sich da wieder rausgekegelt hat. Das lag gar nicht mal daran, weil alle anderen auf einmal so viel besser waren, sondern weil man eben auch unter Quassenjork eben letzte Saison so Phasen hatte in den letzten zwei Jahren, wo man eben nicht so ganz wusste, ja, also wo fällt das denn jetzt ab? Also ist es dann, wir haben es eben als Vorteil bezeichnet, wenn der Druck nicht so da ist, ist es vielleicht hinten raus auch der Nachteil, weil du eben sagst, ja okay, es erwartet ja eh niemand von uns, gerade nicht in dieser Saison. Es ist eine Unbruchssaison mit Ralf Kettemann. Also das darf manchmal vielleicht wirklich Spekulation, aber irgendwie doch die letzte Motivation nicht da ist. Ich meine, man muss auch sagen, die Saisons, die Paderborn in der 1. Liga haben, die haben wir glaube ich alle sehr schnell ehrlich gesagt wieder vergessen, weil sie haben zwar immer mit reingebracht, dass die Spiele durchaus spektakulär waren, aber sie sind eben am Ende der Saison auch meistens relativ sang- und klanglos wieder abgestiegen. Und ich weiß, ich habe das hier schon voll häufig gesagt, aber Paderborn kam ja aus so einer absoluten Berg- und Halffahrt. Also man war ja entweder immer zweiter oder achtzinter und man befindet sich jetzt seit Jahren in dieser Stabilisation und in der zweiten Liga und hat sich immer in diese Top-Teams erarbeitet. Ich würde fast sagen, das ist wie Heidenheim damals. Also irgendwann, dass man dann doch von außen dann doch so leichte Erwartungshaltung hat, ja okay, aber irgendwann muss es ja jetzt auch mal reichen. Also Kader wird vielleicht nicht schlechter. Klar, du hast auch im Trainerstuhl gewechselt, aber das wäre so der einzige Punkt, warum ich sie so auch, warum man irgendwann an den SCP vielleicht auch unfaire Erwartungen hat und vielleicht eben auch, wie gesagt, liebe Grüße an Kevin Bublitz, von dem das eben auch kam, dass man gar nicht mal so zufrieden ist. Gut, ich meine, trotzdem ist es die Klasse, dass man solche Spiele dann positiv beschreitet, aber diese Stabilität, ich glaube, die muss man eben jetzt mal wieder reinkriegen, dass man eben nicht immer diese Hü-Hot-Spieler hat, weil ich weiß, ich wiederhole mich da, aber das kann dir halt im Ende auch so ein bisschen vielleicht die Sicherheit im Endspurt kosten, die man haben möchte, weil also die können mir alles erzählen, was sie wollen, aber auch steigen wollen sie im Endeffekt, glaube ich, alle ganz gerne doch nochmal. Und das werden die Spieler da auch wissen. Gut, ich würde sonst sagen, bevor wir über Teams sprechen mit guter Laune, habe ich noch ein paar Infos und Ankündigungen dabei. Ich verspreche es, es geht ganz schnell. Ihr wisst es, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe-, paywall- und sponsor-frei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich durch eure Beiträge. Und wenn ihr mehr dazu wissen wollt, dann schaut gerne mal in den Show Notes vorbei. Der stellvertretende Dank, der geht heute an Tentakel Tom, Fabian W und Nanobot unter Strich BLN. Gehe davon aus, das steht für Berlin, einem Notch-Show. Aber vielen, vielen Dank, dass ihr schon Rasenfunk-SupporterInnen seid. Wenn ihr es werden wollt, wie gesagt, würden wir uns sehr darüber freuen, natürlich meine Gäste, weil ihr finanziert eben auch damit mit, dass die ein bisschen was bekommen. Und eben auch ich als Moderatorin und vielleicht einfach noch mal der net gemeinte Hinweis, zum 1. Januar sind ja die um 3% von Max angekündigt, die Gehälter da quasi noch mal gestiegen. Wenn ihr das vielleicht unterstützen wollt, dann überlegt doch auch jetzt noch vielleicht auch eure eigenen Beträge um 3% zu erhöhen oder sogar um 5, wenn das den Betrag schöner macht. Vielleicht ein bisschen aufrunden. Das freut den Max bestimmt auch. Sonst ist gestern die Super Bowl-Sendung zur Bundesliga der Männer erschienen. Ich habe sie mir heute Morgen schon angehört. Ich kann sie sehr empfehlen, auch weil man einen Max in einer Direktheit erlebt. Das hat man manchmal sonst nicht. Und die absolute, meine Lieblingsstelle ist die Unglaublichkeit, als rauskommt, dass Sven zu diesem Zeitpunkt das erste Mal Luis Dias und Harry Kane live gesehen hat. Das war, glaube ich, mit meinem Highlight, diese Unglaublichkeit dahinter. Das sind wir doch manchmal sehr gefangen in unserer Fußballblase. Und sonst erscheint heute Abend noch die Sendung zur Bundesliga der Frauen. Letzte Woche ist eine Ligatour Europa erschienen. Da könnt ihr auch gerne reinhören. Sonst letzte Woche zwei Schwerpunkte. Das nächste erscheint dann zur RB Leipzig, aber erst nächste Woche. Puh, das habe ich durchgemacht. Und dann kommen wir zu unserem Gute-Laune-Express Fortuna Düsseldorf. Die stehen auf Platz 14. Momentan, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht vertan habe, es ist Platz 13. Perfekt. Ich kann nicht lesen. 24 Punkte.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, 14.
Es sind sieben Siege, drei unentschieden, elf Niederlagen. Man hängt noch so ein bisschen seiner Hinrunde hinterher, glaube ich. Aber die Formkurve, die zeigt ja sowas von nach oben. Man ist in der Formtabelle auf Platz 4 in den letzten vier Spielen. Zwei Siege, eine Niederlage, ein Unentschieden in diesem neuen Jahr. Und Thorsten, also man muss einfach sagen, wir haben an anderer Stelle, beziehungsweise Mark hatte schon ein bisschen über die Winterneuzugänge gesprochen, deshalb wollen wir da, glaube ich, jetzt heute nicht mehr so einen Fokus drauflegen. Aber was hat sich denn seitdem, ja ich würde jetzt einfach mal den Jahreswechsel sagen, verändert, dass die Fortuna unter Markus Anfang endlich, ja nicht nur häufiger, sondern ehrlich gesagt Spiele gewinnt?
Ja, ja tatsächlich muss man die Grenze oder ab wann es besser wurde, muss man ein bisschen früher schon in den Dezember ziehen, würde ich dazu sagen. Es hat ziemlich lange gedauert, bis der Trainerwechsel so ein bisschen gegriffen hat. Das ist jetzt aber auch insofern nicht verwunderlich. Nicht nur wenn du, nein es war jetzt noch kein Disc gegen Markus Anfang, der vielleicht vermutet wird, aber es sind natürlich schon sehr unterschiedliche Typen, übrigens auch mit einer sehr unterschiedlichen Spielidee. Und wenn man sowas, ich sage jetzt mal im offenen Herzen, mitten in der Saison versucht zu ändern, dann kann das halt schon mal eine Weile dauern. Plus on top die Verunsicherung, die natürlich schon herrschte bei diesem Trainerwechsel. Das hat erstmal ja nun wirklich, das weiß ja jeder, gar nicht funktioniert. Und der Tiefpunkt war eigentlich so Ende November erreicht mit dem Auswärtsspiel in Dresden. Das war dann auch der erste Heimsieg für Dresden, da haben wir Aufbauhilfe da entsprechend betrieben. Und dann gab es halt noch diese unsäglichen Geschichten neben dem Platz, also die rassistische Beleidigung gegen Immanuel Iorre, die Relativierung des Ganzen durch Markus Anfanger. Also wirklich viele unschöne Dinge. Das war so der Stimmungstiefpunkt. Und das ist, wie im griechischen Drama, ist der Tiefpunkt meistens auch der Wendepunkt. So, dass dann da die personellen natürlich auch Entscheidungen getroffen wurden, über die habt ihr ja im Rasenfunk auch schon zur Halbserie gesprochen. Und da durfte ich ja auch schon einen kleinen Kommentar zu abgeben. Also dann wurde Klaus Alofs abberufen. Sven Mislintat kam dann im Dezember als neue Person. Ich hatte eben über das Schalke-Spiel schon gesprochen, dass eigentlich unglücklich verloren wurde. Noch viel unglücklicher war die Niederlage 1-0 in Elbersberg, wo man wirklich klar überlegen war und wirklich größte Torchancen nicht genutzt hat und kurz vor Schluss einen selber reinbekommt hat. Selbst der Elbersberger Trainer, Vincent Wagner, hat da hinterher zugegeben, dass es ein verdammt glücklicher Sieg für sie gewesen sei. Und da fing diese Tendenz an und dann gab es das Spiel gegen Fürth. Da hat Michi bestimmt auch eine Meinung zu dieser Partie. Aber da würde ich jetzt sagen, täuscht das Ergebnis darüber hinweg, wie klar der Unterschied in dieser Partie war. Also da fand ich Fürth auch wirklich, wirklich schwach, muss ich sagen. Und da war es einmal mehr unsere Offensivproblematik, dass wir eigentlich nur zwei Tore in dem Spiel geschossen haben. Und am Ende haben wir euch den Elber noch geschenkt, warum auch immer in der Nachspielzeit des Spiels. Aber das hat dann das Ergebnis noch mal ein bisschen verändert. Und da war halt Sven Mislintat da. Und was man sagen muss, was Sven Mislintat reingebracht hat, entgegen, sagen wir mal, der populären Meinung über ihn in der Öffentlichkeit, ob berechtigt oder nicht, ist jetzt an dieser Stelle, kann man das vermutlich nicht klären. Er hat Ruhe reingebracht und nicht Unruhe. Und das ist tatsächlich ein Faktor nach dieser wilden Hinrunde, über die ja auch im Rasenfunk IV gesprochen wurde, dass da einer ist, der natürlich erst mal die Steine ein bisschen gewendet hat. Christian Weber ist ja auch gegangen als Sportdirektor, nicht nur Klaus Alofs etc. Aber sich dann ja auch nach dem Viert-Spiel dafür entschieden hat, zu sagen, nee, Markus Anfang bleibt unser Trainer. Ich habe mit vielen Leuten gesprochen, mit der Mannschaft viel gesprochen und mir die Arbeit selber angeguckt. Und das Spiel gegen Viert war ja auch überzeugend von Fortuna, muss man sagen. Es war am 17. Spieltag unser bestes Heimspiel oder unser bestes Saisonspiel. Das sagt dann auch ein bisschen was aus natürlich über die Hinserie. Und ja, dann ging man so in dieser Konstellation ins Trainingslager. Viele, auch wir, von unserem Podcast haben schon gesagt, es könnte jetzt aber ein Problem sein, wenn nämlich das erste Spiel gegen Bielefeld verloren geht, dann hast du die Trainer-Diskussion sofort wieder da. Also das ist ja erstmal in dem Moment kein Versprechen auf Dauer. Und dann war halt das Trainingslager in Marbella, mein Kollege Andy vom Podcast und ich, wir waren auch dort vor Ort, haben da ja auch einen Podcast mit Eva aufgenommen. Und da konnte man sich halt so die Trainingsarbeit auch mal ein bisschen angucken aus nächster Nähe und auch die Stimmung. Und da muss man schon sagen, man hatte fast den Eindruck bei der Stimmung, dass die Mannschaft irgendwo im Aufstiegskampf ist. Die war wirklich positiv und man hatte jetzt nicht das Gefühl, dass hier überall Grabenkämpfe herrschen und dass sich alle gegenseitig oder dass alle versuchen, das sinkende Schiff sozusagen zu verlassen. Es gibt immer ein paar Ausnahmen. Auch im Trainingslager war nicht alles rosarot, aber man konnte sehen, okay, im Training, das ist, also ich hatte wirklich einen positiven Eindruck von Markus Anfang, sagen wir mal als Coach auf der, also in der klassischen Trainingsarbeit. Da wurden viele Dinge eingeübt, die ich jetzt in den Spielen auch durchaus wiedererkennen kann. Also das würde ich ihm uneingeschränkt auch wirklich auf die Fahne schreiben. Da hat er es jetzt endlich geschafft, einen neuen spielerisch auch besseren Ansatz der Mannschaft, ich wollte gerade einimpfen sagen, beizubringen und hat ein bisschen gedauert. Und das ist ihm also durchaus gelungen, gleichzeitig mit eben, ja man hat es dann geschafft im Trainingslager so eine gewisse Aufbruchsstimmung für die Rückrunde reinzubringen. Ganz klar, ich habe mich mit Sven Mislint auch unterhalten in Spanien und er meinte halt auch, das ist jetzt alles hier nichts wert, wenn wir gegen Bielefeld nicht gewinnen. Wir müssen das jetzt auch in Punkte umdrehen. Darum waren wir alle sehr, sehr– das hast du mir nicht angemerkt an dem Tag– wir waren wirklich alle sehr, sehr angespannt in Düsseldorf, weil halt klar war, nach diesem Spiel gegen Fürth, was auch schon gewonnen werden musste, dass man in dieser Drucksituation nochmal bestehen musste. Und ich glaube, das hat der Mannschaft erstmal geholfen, dass man zwei wirklich, man war zur Erinnerung, wir waren zwischenzeitlich 17. Wir waren einfach, wir mussten diese Spiele gewinnen, um nicht hier schon vornherein in so einer negativen Spirale weiter drin zu sein. Wenn man das als Mannschaft schafft, das meinte ich nämlich auch bei Bielefeld jetzt gegen Braunschweig, das kann Kräfte dann freisetzen. Das Selbstvertrauen wird größer, die Stimmung wird nochmal besser, man geht dann lockerer ran. Klar, dann kam jetzt das zweite Spiel in Hannover. Das hat man verloren, man hat es auch verdient verloren, allerdings gab es auch eine rote Karte für Fortuna, die also auch korrekt war und alles. Und man hat es dann danach durchaus offen halten können, aber Hannover hätte bei besserer Chancenverwertung das Spiel gewinnen können. Und Hannover zeigt dir jetzt auch, dass mit ihnen auch wieder ganz oben zu rechnen ist. Also ich will damit sagen, keine Schande dort zu verlieren. Und wenn man sieht, wie chancenlos Kiel da entsprechend war und die Hütte vollbekommen hat, also ganz so schlimm war es bei uns zum Beispiel da nicht. Aber jetzt kamen halt so die nächsten Spiele und da war natürlich jetzt das Paderborn-Spiel auch nochmal wichtig. Also man merkt einfach dieses Flänzchen Selbstvertrauen, das wächst und gedeiht. Und jetzt war man halt auch in Karlsruhe gestern. Wie ich fand, die bessere Mannschaft hat auch da jetzt den spielerischen Ansatz, man sieht den halt inzwischen. Man hat jetzt zwar nicht über Ballbesitz dominiert, aber es wurde jetzt das System gewechselt, das ist übrigens vor dem Viertelspiel passiert und das ist sicherlich auch ein Teil jetzt für die bessere Kompaktheit. Man spielt also jetzt in einem entweder 3-5-2 oder in einem 3-4-2-1 mit einer Dreierkette, die sehr gut funktioniert. Da ist unter anderem Elias Egoli, unser 2,04 Meter Mann in der Mitte, den kennt man vielleicht noch nicht so gut. Der ist da aber ein wirklich wichtiger Spieler, Innenverteidiger, der groß und kopfballstark ist, bei 2,04 Meter, aber gleichzeitig schnell. Und das ist natürlich ein Profil, was man in der Größe normalerweise nicht hat. Denn machen wir uns nichts vor, die meisten 1,90 Innenverteidiger, haben eher so einen Wendekreis wie ein Schlachtschiff, aber sind da meistens in Laufduellen entsprechend nicht so einsatzfähig. Und dadurch haben wir es jetzt geschafft, eine sowohl kopfballstärke als auch z.B. mit Kenneth Schmidt neben ihm, der ebenfalls ein relativ schneller Innenverteidiger ist, und gleichzeitig nicht langsam Abwehr zu haben. Was, wenn du einen spielerischen Ansatz hast und dein Team jetzt höher steht, wirklich kein Nachteil ist. Weil sonst läufst du halt in diese blöden Kontersituationen. Das heißt, es hat personelle Gründe, die Dinge kommen da zusammen, der spielerische Ansatz funktioniert einfach besser und es kommt das Selbstvertrauen Pöa Pöa. Das klingt jetzt aber alles viel zu rosarot und darum muss ich natürlich auch was in den Wein gießen.
Warte, ganz kurz Thorsten, bevor du das machst, ich frage mal ganz kurz Michi, weil ich habe schon eben den Gesichtsausdruck gesehen, als es kam mit, ja, nach Tiefpunkten wie in der griechischen Tragödie, geht es ja meistens auch wieder bergauf. Ich sah Zweifel in den Augen. Ganz kurz, um dich einmal kurz mit reinzuholen, bevor Thorsten was in den Wein gießt.
Monologisiert, ja.
Du bist natürlich auch eigentlich nicht so ganz daran interessiert, als Begleiter des Fürther Fußballs, dass Vereine wie Düsseldorf sich dann da wieder rauskraxeln, ehrlich gesagt. Vielleicht einfach mal mit so zwei, drei Sätzen. Wie siehst du denn die Düsseldorfer Entwicklung jetzt in 2026?
Also wenn ich an meinen Tabellentipp vor der Saison denke, bin ich sehr daran interessiert, dass Düsseldorf da rauskraxelt. Da würde ich nicht ganz so schlecht ausschauen. Da kommt noch ein weiterer Verein, über den wir auch noch sprechen in dieser Folge, die schon wieder sehr lange geraten ist. Die habe ich da auch sehr weit oben hingetippt. Da sind sie noch ein bisschen weg davon. Insofern, ja, am Ende muss ich mich Thorsten anschließen. Ich habe die Fortuna ja auch live gesehen bei dem Spiel gegen Viertel. Da waren es die Tabellen 17. gegen den Tabellen 15. damals. Da hat aber er gefühlt einen Platz 8 gegen Platz 18 gespielt. Also da war die Fortuna einfach deutlich besser. Da hatten sie, glaube ich, 10 zu 0 Schüsse nach einer halben Stunde und so weiter. Also das war insgesamt ein Auftritt, von dem man dachte, okay, diese Mannschaft wird da unten nicht lange mehr drin sein. Sie ist es jetzt weiterhin. Das liegt aber daran, dass in diesem Jahr keinen Ulmen-Ringsburg dabei sind, die so komplett abgeschlagen sind, also führt so in Ansätze. Aber ansonsten ist es halt extrem eng. Aber diese individuelle Qualität, diese Fortentwicklung, die es dort gibt, die ich in dem Spiel live gesehen habe, die sich jetzt noch weiter fortgesetzt hat, das sind sehr viele Bausteine, die dafür sprechen, dass die Fortuna wahrscheinlich am Ende nicht nur den letzten 3 sein wird, wo sie landet. Das ist, glaube ich, hypothetisch zu sagen. Sie wird nicht da landen, wo ich sie getippt habe. Das wird ein sehr weiter Weg bis dahin. Da müsste schon sehr, sehr vieles gut laufen und das Diamantenauge vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr finden als Diamanten. Aber ich bin auch bei der Fortuna guter Dinge. Und irgendwann werden die Mannschaften halt weniger, bei denen ich glaube, dass sie da noch hinter Föhr trutschen können. Aber das ist wieder ein anderes Thema.
Thorsten, bevor du zu deinem– oder ich frage das vielleicht mal so. Die nächsten Spiele sind zu Hause gegen Münster und auswärts in Darmstadt. Was denn vielleicht an der aktuellen Situation sagt denn bei dir noch? Also so ganz rosarot ist es doch noch nicht alles.
Naja, zum einen, ich kann ja auch die Tabelle lesen. Es ist ja einfach eine Tabellenkonstellation. Wenn du jetzt einfach mal zwei Spiele verlierst und sowas, kann ja einfach in der 2. Liga immer passieren. Dann kannst du halt auch auf Platz 17 wieder stehen. Und dann hast du halt auch wieder eine Druckkulisse. Und dann kann es auch vielleicht wieder Diskussionen in Richtung Trainer geben, die jetzt zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt einfach kontraproduktiv sind. Im Moment geht es einfach darum, ruhig zu arbeiten, ob man jetzt von Markus Anfang komplett überzeugt ist oder nicht. Aber Ruhe hilft eindeutig mehr als Diskussionen gerade, was dieses Thema betrifft. Aber es gibt natürlich auch noch andere Gründe. Und das ist das Wasser, das ich in den Wein gießen wollte. Denn die Probleme, die Fortuna in der Hinserie hatte, die sind jetzt nicht aus der Welt auf einmal. Also es hat sich natürlich was spielerisch gebessert. Aber die Offensive bleibt das Sorgenkind. Wenn wir uns das anschauen. Wir sind extremst abhängig da von Cedric Itten, der glücklicherweise dank seiner Qualität, und den kennt Michael ja auch noch ganz gut, aus dem halben Jahr in der Bundesliga, glaube ich, bei Fürth, der als Einfacher schafft, uns in vielen Spielen als Zielstürmer oder dann auch gegen Bielefeld in der Schlussphase so eine Ecke reinzuköpfen. Er ist einfach der Unterschiedsspieler, was die Offensive betrifft. Wenn man aber schaut, er hat nahezu die Hälfte unserer Tore geschossen. Das sind sowieso nicht viele, sind immer noch die wenigsten. Wir haben die 20 jetzt geknackt. So, es geht jetzt los, Freunde. Aber das ist halt tatsächlich noch ein großes Problem, dass die Mannschaft insgesamt nicht genug Torgefahr entwickelt. Da kann ich auch Eva an die Partie gegen Bielefeld erinnert. Die hat nämlich sehr schön zusammengefasst, wo die Probleme liegen, aber eigentlich auch gegen Fürth. Wir haben aber gegen Bielefeld, weil der erste Teil etwas evidenter. Wir haben halt das Problem, dass wir entweder zwar gefällig kombinieren, aber gar nicht erst so in den Strafraum so reinkommen für Chancen. Das war die erste Halbzeit gegen Bielefeld. Oder wir haben die Chancen, zweite Halbzeit gegen Bielefeld oder das Spiel gegen Fürth, und wir vergeben viel zu viele davon. Und das war selbst gestern in Karlsruhe so ein bisschen der Fall. In der ersten Halbzeit war es auch ganz wenig Szenen im Tor, aber wir haben Karlsruhe gut von unserem eigenen Tor weggehalten. Das gelingt uns insgesamt, wenn wir jetzt Hannover das Spiel mal ein bisschen ausklammern, aber selbst da ehrlicherweise nach dem Rückstand. Das gelingt uns inzwischen sehr, sehr gut, die Gegner vom eigenen Tor fernzuhalten. Wir haben aber Phasen im Spiel drin, wo wir selber nicht torgefährlich werden und die sind noch zu lang. Und wenn wir torgefährlich werden, dann gibt es neben ittenwenig Spieler, die Tore machen. Das wurde jetzt allerdings adressiert. Ein bisschen Bogen muss ich noch zu Transfers ziehen, die nämlich passiert sind, nachdem die letzte Folge veröffentlicht wurde. Also über Tanaka habt ihr schon gesprochen. Der agiert auch nach wie vor wirklich ganz, ganz hervorragend. Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Mosaikstein. Wer den einmal live sieht, der hat keine Fragen mehr, warum Tanaka uns gerade weiterhilft im defensiven Mittelfeld. Und jetzt hat aber Sven Misslindt, hat ja auch noch, wir hatten Jordi Paulina geholt. Ich glaube, das war jetzt nicht ein großes Thema. Er ist auch noch angeschlagen, war jetzt auch am Wochenende wieder nicht im Kader. Ich glaube, krankheitsbedingt. Der hat noch keine Rolle gespielt. Stürmer von der 2. Mannschaft von Borussia Dortmund aus Curaçao, der noch WM-Chancen hat. Es könnte übrigens sein, dass Curaçao mit einem Fortunasturm antritt, beim Spiel gegen Deutschland, bei der Weltmeisterschaft. Denn Charlison Benchop, den ja vielleicht einige noch kennen, aus der 2. Liga, der ja auch eine Fortuna-Vergangenheit hatte, spielt inzwischen für die 2. Mannschaft von Fortuna, 36 Jahre alt, ist auch noch Nationalspieler von Curaçao. Und es könnte sein, dass Paulina und Benchop bei der WM dann entsprechend antreten. Das ist so ein kleiner Traum bei den Fortuna-Fans. Und man hat halt erkannt, er ist jetzt nicht so ein direkter Ersatz für Cedric Itten, sondern gerade wenn wir in 3-5-2 mit zwei Stürmern spielen, das ist vielleicht noch ein zweiten Stürmer, der nicht so diesen klassischen Mittelstürmer-Prototyp, auch wenn Paulina 1.91 ist, entspricht, sondern so ein bisschen um ihn herumspielen kann. Das war auch mehr so seine Rolle bei Borussia Dortmund 2. Und das Gleiche gilt dann vielleicht noch sehr viel mehr. Und das ist jetzt sozusagen so ein Soforthilfen-Leihe, auch ohne Kaufoption, mit Marin Ljubicic, den wir von Union Berlin jetzt ausgeliehen haben. Ein eher spielerischer Stürmer, anderer Typ als Itten, wo man sich aber, ich glaube, wenn man sich so diese Kombis anguckt, also wir reden vielleicht noch über Bochum, aber Hoffmann jetzt und Marshal ist auch so ein Sturmduo, das sehr unterschiedliche Eigenschaften hat und sich dadurch relativ gut ergänzt. Und das ist die Idee hinter diesem Transfer. Ljubicic ist allerdings angeschlagen gekommen, hat jetzt die letzten zwei Wochen noch nicht trainieren können. Die Woche ist jetzt kurz, Münsterspiel ist schon am Freitag, darum würde ich diese Woche noch nicht mit ihm rechnen. Aber auf Sicht ist da also auch personell und gerade, also siebe ich das Wasser wieder raus aus dem Wein, hört ihr ja jetzt gerade, also da ist auf Sicht vielleicht noch die Chance, dass wir da auch ein bisschen was machen, dadurch, dass wir da auch personell jetzt noch ein bisschen was getan haben, ohne dass das zum Tragen gekommen ist. Und ich höre auch gleich auf, keine Sorge. Ein kleiner Shoutout, den möchte ich jetzt aus der Karlsruhe-Partie noch an Christopher Lenz tatsächlich rausgeben.
Den hatte ich auch noch auf der Liste.
Genau, Christopher Lenz. Ja, Christopher Lenz spielt bei Fortuna Düsseldorf. Und zwar schon seit Sommer. Nur das Geheimnis ist, er spielte halt nicht. Und zwar nicht leistungsbedingt, sondern verletzungsbedingt. Er hatte ja die letzten zwei Jahre sowohl bei Leipzig als auch Hoffenheim, war er mehr oder weniger komplett verletzt ausgefallen. Es gab dann im Sommer den Gamble, diesen Spieler zu holen, wo viele inklusive uns gesagt haben, also mit der verletzten Historie und unserem Track-Record auf der links-verteidiger Position, das kann doch nur schiefgehen. Und genau so war es in der Hinrunde, er war praktisch die komplette Hin-Serie. Verletzt ist aber jetzt seit dem Trainingslager, das er vollkommen bestritten hat, wieder herangeführt. Es hat jetzt ein paar Wochen gedauert über Einwechslungen und jetzt gab es den ersten Startelf-Einsatz, er hat gleich das Tor von Itten entsprechend vorbereitet. Und das ist ein bisschen nicht nur Routine, sondern vor allem auch Kommunikation auf dem Platz. Ich habe den Mann im Trainingslager gesehen, das ist Radio Lenz, das ist der neue Sender. Der Mann redet wirklich sehr, sehr viel. Sind die anderen auch manchmal von genervt? Das konnte man bei einem ganz sympathischen, also es war jetzt kein ernster Disput, aber sie haben sehr erregt diskutiert zwischen Muslia und Imen Karlsruhe, konnte man sehr gut einmal sehen bei einer Szene. Und das fehlt dieser Mannschaft, die ist ein bisschen ruhig, das fand ich auch evident in den Trainings. Da wird nicht so viel gesprochen, ist ja auch immer so eine Kommunikationsfrage, wie Ella Susi, der kein Deutsch oder nur bedingt Englisch spricht, und dann Tanaka, wie sprechen die alle miteinander auf dem Feld, ist nicht immer so einfach. Und ich glaube, so ein Spieler ist da durchaus hilfreich. Und ich glaube, auch das wird uns noch ein bisschen mehr was bringen, denn wir haben eigentlich einen Zielspieler für sehr gute Flanken in der Mitte mit Itten. Und jetzt haben wir auch einen Flankenspieler, der die vielleicht bringen könnte. Und das war dann auch ein Grund, warum man letztendlich da auch keine Außenbahnspieler mehr jetzt geholt hat, weil nämlich auch Weiger Lündal endlich wieder fit ist auf der rechten Seite. Also ich glaube, ja, das wird besser. Die Probleme sind aber immer noch da. Die kann man noch erkennen. Hätten wir eine bessere Chancenverwertung, hätten wir auch in Karlsruhe gewonnen. Ich habe jetzt gar keine Lust mehr. Und weil die Zeit fortgeschritten ist, über den Ausgleich von Karlsruhe und mögliche VAR-Eingriffe da zu reden, kann sich ja jeder mal angucken. Wurde teilweise nicht so breit besprochen, aber ich fand das Tor ehrlicherweise irregulär. Und ich fand, das lag eine aktive Abseits-Stellung vor. Aber müssen wir an dieser Stelle jetzt hier nicht aufklären. Aber grundsätzlich ist man auf dem Weg. Das Heimspiel gegen Münster wird jetzt sicherlich ein wichtiges. Aber ich bin auch zuversichtlich, auch wenn ich mir Münster so in den letzten Wochen anschaue, dass wir das vielleicht auch vor uns entscheiden können. Das kann noch mal wichtig sein. In Darmstadt werden die Früchte hochhängen, aber manchmal ist das ja auch nicht so verkehrt. Mit so einer Ausgangsposition. Danach kommt Bochum, Nürnberg. Also es sind alles wichtige Duelle. Aber die Mannschaft hat jetzt gezeigt, dass sie in wichtigen Duellen auch mental der Situation gewachsen ist. Sodass ich jetzt nicht mehr von großen tabellarchischen Sprühen ausgehe, weil ich sehe jetzt nicht, dass wir noch auf Platz 6 landen. Aber ich glaube schon, dass wir uns qua unserer Qualität da sukzessive entfernen können. Und natürlich ist das auch immer ein bisschen Hoffnung.
Ja, sind wir mal gespannt, was wir da von der Fortuna noch erwarten können. Aber wir haben ja noch zwei Vereine, durch die können wir jetzt ein bisschen flotter auch durchgehen. Und das ist zum einen Hannover 96, Platz 5, 38 Punkte, 38 zu 28 Tore, 1. Siege, 5 Unentschieden und 5 Niederlagen. Und sie sind in der Formtabelle in den letzten vier Spielen auf Platz 1. 3 Siege, 1 Niederlage. Die Niederlage, das war das ganz zu Beginn dieser Sendung. Oh jees, erinnern sich vielleicht noch die 1 zu 3 Niederlage in Kaiserslautern. Aber danach gab es eben 3 Siege gegen Fortuna, gegen Magdeburg und gegen Kiel. Es gab einen Umbrauch in der Winterpause, das ganz kurz noch dazu. Wir haben vor der, also im hinrundenden Fazit haben wir darüber noch spekuliert, weil es eben schon im Raum stand, dass Markus Mann Hannover 96 verlassen wird. Jörg Schmatke hat den Posten übernommen. Ich sag mal so, bei den Hannover-Fans, die ich kenne, wurde das jetzt auch nicht mit der größten Überzeugung angenommen. Weil Jörg Schmatke ist halt Jörg Schmatke, aber er hat direkt die Arbeit aufgenommen. Thorassons Saat und Weißhaupt sind die namenhaftesten Neuzugänge. Das wurde aber eben, also generell gerade auch so Weißhaupt und Saat, das wurde in der letzten Folge schon besprochen, deshalb würde ich da tatsächlich auch so ein bisschen sagen, okay, schieben wir hier jetzt mal ein bisschen zur Seite. Michi, man muss glaube ich sagen, Hannover 96 macht endlich wieder die Tore, die sie zuletzt eben nicht gemacht hat. Also es ist wieder die zweitbeste Offensive der Liga. Man hat die meisten Großchancen, aber auch die meisten vergebenden Großchancen, also 88 zu 59, das ist schon deutlich sehbar. Aber man muss eben sagen, gerade mit klar weiterhin Benjamin Kelmer, bester Torschützer inzwischen der Liga, man ist wieder, man greift endlich wieder oben an, könnte man sagen.
Ja, und das ist ja auch vollkommen zu Recht, du hast die Zeilen jetzt angesprochen. Man kann aber auch dann über die noch gar nicht so oft genannten Expected Goals sprechen. Laut Fortbaup hat man 46,9, das sind 47 Tore, die man sich statistisch erspielt hat und man hat erst 38 daraus gemacht. Also wenn man von der berühmten Regression zur Mitte ausgeht, damit die auch mal in dieser Folge genannt ist, dann wird man noch viel Spaß an Hannover 96 haben und vor allem werden die Fans dort sehr viel Spaß haben. Und auch das ist eine Mannschaft, ich habe es vorhin ein bisschen schon gespoilert, die dann auch dem FC Schalke da oben gefährlich werden kann, wenn sie nämlich mit dieser offensiven Qualität so weiter macht. Es gab ja den Anfang der Saison, wo alle schon dachten, okay, die marschieren da komplett durch und am Ende steigen sie mit 102 Punkten auf. Das hat nicht ganz geklappt, aber sie nähern sich dem Ganzen jetzt wieder zumindest ein bisschen an mit diesen Siegen, die sie jetzt hatten oder geholt haben. Ja, und wenn man sich so viele Torchancen und Großchancen und so weiter rausspielt, ja, da kann man den Wasser in den Wein gießen und sagen, sie vergeben die, aber sie spielen sie sich heraus. Und mit der individuellen Qualität, die sie jetzt auch mit Saad nochmal dazu gewonnen haben, man geht auch so ganz verständlich drüber. Jokota, der war letztes Jahr bei Kaiserslautern eigentlich der beste Spieler dieser Mannschaft. Der spielt jetzt halt in Hannover. Mir hat auch ein Viertel verantwortlich einmal gesagt, sie wollen gar nicht wissen, wie viel die Leihgebühr für Elia Saad, was Hannover da leisten kann, finanziell um so einen Spieler mal zu holen. Insofern, ja, es läuft sehr vieles, sehr gut. Aber es hat auch Hannover 96, die da auch jedes Jahr sehr viel investieren. Also kann man fast schon auch erwarten, dass es gut läuft. Also das muss man schon auch immer dazu sagen. Aber sie machen gerade sehr viel Spaß. Christian Titz ist ja bekannt für schönen Fußball. Nicht immer dafür, dass es am Ende dann dazu führt, dass man aufsteigt. Aber zumindest sind sie jetzt wieder komplett oben damit dran. Und in der Form, in der sie sind, mit Kählmann hast du angesprochen, zwölf Tore. Also eins fehlt sie noch, dann hat auch Ebn Talib verdrängt. Das sollte er noch schaffen im Rest der Saison, weil Ebn Talib immer viele 2. Liga-Tore schießen wird in den nächsten Monaten. Würde ich jetzt mal so tippen. Und dann würde ich davon ausgehen, dass Hannover 96 da aber ganz lange ein ganz großes und lautes Wörtchen mitreden wird um den Aufstieg, weil einfach zu vieles zu gut läuft, damit man anderer Meinung sein könnte.
Ja, da will ich auf jeden Fall mitgehen. Und ich glaube, also ich weiß so die Stimmung bei Hannover-Fans, die war so gerade in der Winterpause, die war nicht so sonderlich gut, kurz. Also weil man hatte dieses Spiel gegen Bochum, wo eigentlich niemand so richtig weiß, warum gewinnen wir das eigentlich nicht. Dann hattest du die Niederlage gegen Nürnberg, die haben wir ja auch besprochen, wo man eigentlich sagen muss, also wie man sich selber zwei Tore so reinlegen kann, das ist eigentlich unfassbar. Und dann startest du eigentlich in 2026 und Christ spät eben diese Gegentore gegen Innskals, das Lautern, wo man eigentlich auch genauso sagen kann, ist jetzt eigentlich kein 3-1-Spiel, wenn du dir das angeguckt hast. Und dann, wo ich glaube, bei vielen Hannover-Fans irgendwie so ein bisschen ansprang, so okay, also was ist hier jetzt los? Aber diesen Turnaround geschafft zu haben und ich weiß, ihr könnt meinetwegen, ich kann auch 5 Euro ins Phrasenschein zahlen für meine eigenen Phrasen, aber es ist einfach so, du kommst in dieser Liga nur durch Kontinuität. Und also das kann in beide Richtungen gehen, wenn du kontinuierlich scheiße bist, sorry, aber dann mich die Hände hoch, wenn alle dies nur hören und ich sehen kann, dann wird es halt irgendwann schwer, weil du dich da, also dann musst du da schon wirklich einen großen Aufwand betreiben, da wieder rauszukommen. Aber wenn du es andersherum schaffst, vielleicht aus so einer Schwächerphase wieder rauszukommen und dann eben direkt zu sagen, okay, wir gewinnen jetzt nicht nur ein Spiel, sondern wir gewinnen jetzt auch wirklich die drei Spiele hintereinander und dann zu sagen, hey, wir haben das in der Hinrunde doch schon geschafft. Also, to be fair, man gewinnt jetzt gerade die Spiele, die man auch in der Hinrunde gewonnen hat. Michi, du hast es eben angesprochen. Also, wir müssen dann sicherlich nochmal gucken, wann dieser Cut kam, wann das eben war, was passiert in den Spielen gegen Dresden, glaube ich, und so war das, wo man zwischendurch sagen konnte, so was war das denn jetzt eigentlich. Also, ich glaube, das wird so ein bisschen der Punkt, wo man mal wieder drauf gucken muss, aber man muss endlich sagen, wirklich offensiv ist man endlich wieder da und kann auch sagen, in Hannover ist fantastische Laune wieder, der Hype-Train. Er rollt wieder und man muss ja auch sagen, also für Hannover-Verhältnisse ist dieser Wechsel auf der Geschäftsführerposition ja auch verhältnismäßig. Vielleicht lag es an Weihnachten, man weiß es nicht so genau. Ruhigera verlaufen, also das hätte ja auch richtig in die Hose gehen können, weil ich erinnere nochmal um das ganze Drama mit EV und 50 plus eins und Martin Kind und Weisungsbefundnis und so. Also das wird weiterhin auch wirklich spannend, weil wir wissen alle, dass da noch einfach ein Urteil aussteht vom Kartellamt, was wir dann noch bekommen von der DFL, aber erst mal da. Man hätte schlechter treffen können, so rund um Thorsten.
Ja, ich wollte dazu noch ergänzen, weil ich nämlich genau nach der Auftaktniederlage und vor unserem Spiel in einem Hannover-Podcast Vorwärts nach weit, liebe Grüße, an dieser Stelle zu Gast war. Und die Stimmungslage da entsprach, also entsprechend der, die du gerade genannt hattest, da ging es schon ein bisschen um die Frage, ob Jörg Schmatke, denn das darf man nicht vergessen, Titz ist ja nicht sein Trainer, ob der, wenn das jetzt gegen Düsseldorf schief geht, da nicht sogar schon die Reißleine ziehen könnte bei Christian Titz. Und es ist natürlich jetzt anders gekommen. Und um das bei Michi zu ergänzen, also Jokota war der entscheidende Spieler gegen uns und auch jetzt sonst, würde ich sagen, einer der insgesamt herausragenden Spieler dieser Rückrunde bisher, der zeigt eigentlich jetzt erst so richtig, was in ihm steckt, auch bei Hannover, was er eben in Lautern schon gezeigt hatte. Und deine These zu den XG oder den Expected Goals, gestern wurde die nochmal bestätigt. Expected Goals gegen Kiel 4,4 zu 0,6. Also das ist schon ein Wert, der dann auch klar macht, wie chancenlos Kiel eigentlich in dieser Partie letztendlich war. Und ja, die Transfers im Winter, das ist auf jeden Fall eine klare Ansage. Das Interessante ist ja, dass Vereine wie Hannover härter sind. Wir sind komplett da raus, lautern inzwischen so ein bisschen, auch Schalke jetzt neu. Das sind ja die Vereine, die wirklich investiert haben, um aufzusteigen. Und wenn wir mal rasch durchzählen, dann stellen wir fest, na, sie werden es nicht alle schaffen. Das heißt, bei denen, wo es schief geht, da wird es spannend zu sein, wie die Perspektive über die Saison hinaus geht. Und Hannover ist da so ein Verein. Wenn das nicht klappt, bin ich sehr gespannt, wie es in diesem Sommer bei Hannover dann weitergeht. Jetzt nicht finanziell, dass es zusammenbricht, sondern kommt der nächste Turnaround, weil das, wir erinnern uns, 3-Jahresplan mit Leiteln und dann steigen wir auf. Das wurde alles über den Haufen geworfen und die letzte Rückrunde. Und jetzt wurde ja im Grunde unfreiwillig natürlich der sportliche Leiter da getauscht. Aber ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, sollte es nochmal in die andere Richtung gehen, dass Jörg Schmatke sehr viel Geduld beweisen wird. Denn ich glaube nicht, dass er gekommen ist, um in der 2. Liga dort mit Hannover dann im Sommer nochmal dort zu versuchen und dann im Winter nochmal und so weiter. Also so wie Hannover die letzten Jahre performt hat, wird Jörg Schmatke das nicht lange mitmachen. Prophezeie ich. Denn er ist ja auch jemand, der gerne mal dazu neigt, die Sachen hinzuwerfen. Das sollten wir vielleicht an der Stelle nicht vergessen.
Ja, ich bin mal gespannt, weil man muss ehrlich gesagt auch sagen, also trotz allem und trotz der Offensive, die Hannover auch gefahren hat, trotzdem muss man ja sagen, es war von Anfang an klar, dass es eben auch eine Umbruchssaison wird. Das ist eine Leier, die fahre ich hier in Bielefeld auch immer wieder. Wie sinnvoll es ist, ein Kader, der zu 90 Prozent auf einen Trainer zugeschnitten ist und auf das, was einen Trainer spielen lassen will, zu diesem Zeitpunkt jetzt, wo du eben transvertechnisch auch nichts mehr machen kannst, dann zu sagen, wir gehen den Weg nicht weiter. Also das ist meine feste Überzeugung, warum das in Bielefeld absolut keinen Sinn machen würde, mit Kniat nicht mehr als Trainer zu haben, weil wenn man das so hört, kommen 60% der Spieler einfach wegen mit Kniat und mit der Art und Weise, wie er sie überzeugt. Ist eben immer so ein bisschen die Frage, wie sinnvoll das ist. Klar, ihr habt jetzt gerade Xtreme Wert angepackt, da wäre Hannover übrigens auch laut FODMOP auf Platz 1, gefolgt von Paderborn, Elbersberg, Schalke, also auch sehr interessant.
Übrigens bei Übersitz Pass Quote übrigens auch Platz 1.
Komisch, gefolgt von Magdeburg, komisch. Führt übrigens auch da auf Platz 18. Ich dachte, ich sag's nur nochmal.
Wo denn nicht? Das wären die interessanteren Fakten.
Jetzt wird's langsam gemeint.
Ich sag nur, was am Tisch steht. Da übrigens Fortuna Düsseldorf auf Platz 14. Ich sag's nur, ich glaube, dass...
Ja, ja, das entspricht ja dem Tabellenplatz, wie sie so gesehen.
Aber gut, das hätten wir dann auch geklärt. Nee, aber also generell, ich muss auch einfach sagen, vielleicht ist es die Nähe auch, aber keine Ahnung. Ich würde es im Jahr Anova auch mal wieder gönnen, Bundesliga zu spielen. Man weiß nie, was passiert. Wie gesagt, wir müssen gerade bei 96 auch immer auf die besondere Konstellation im Verein schauen. Es ist eine ewige Leier, aber per se, ganz ehrlich, Niedersachsen-Stadion auch immer wieder ein Besuch wert, da direkt am Marschsee.
Ich finde es…
Also im Januar war es Schweine kalt.
Aber wo war es nicht Schweine kalt im Januar, ich bin ganz ehrlich, warm fand ich es jetzt bei euch auch nicht. Und das trotz Plusgrade. Also ich sage es, wie es ist.
Also in Marbella war es sehr warm.
Aber ich würde sonst sagen, nächste Spiele, ausschließlich bei der Hertha, sehr interessant. Und dann zu Hause gegen Dresden. Das ist eine dieser, also das sind zwei sehr interessante Partien, weil einmal willst du Hertha natürlich tabellarisch jetzt von dir weghalten. Das ist klar. Und Dresden ist gerade jemand, der gerade vor allem Vereine von da oben, die können dich schon ganz gut ärgern, weil sie da eben sich auch, wir haben es eben schon besprochen und es wurde in der letzten Folge auch schon besprochen, sie haben dich schon weiterentwickelt, was glaube ich manche auch in der Winterpause so nicht erwartet haben. Also da muss man auch sagen, Respekt da nochmal nach Dresden. Aber ich würde sagen, wir kommen jetzt mal schneller zum Spiel. Ich habe hier schon wieder alle meine Zeitvorgaben irgendwie getoppt. Das war natürlich niemandem klar, außer mir selber. Wir schauen noch ganz kurz auf den VfL Bochum, denn das ist ein Verein ähnlich, wie wir das eben bei Paderborn hatten. Es ist vielleicht nicht auf dem ersten Grund ersichtlich, warum wir darüber jetzt sprechen, aber man muss einfach sagen, von da, wo der VfL Bochum kommt, sie stehen jetzt auf Platz 8. Sie haben 27 Punkte, 30 zu 27 Tore, 7 Siege, 6 Unentschieden, 8 Niederlagen. Sie sind auf Platz 7 der Formtabelle. Also ganz interessant, ein Platz über dem SC Paderborn. Es war zwar nur ein Sieg, glaube ich, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht auch schon wieder vertan habe. Genau, ein Sieg, 3 Unentschieden bzw. 4 Unentschieden, wenn man noch quasi davor guckt. Man muss aber eben sagen, man ist seit fast 9 Spielen nun ungeschlagen, was unter Uwe Rößler durchaus eine positive Bilanz weiterhin ist. Man hat u.a. eben gegen Schalke 04 gewonnen, dieses, ich möchte sagen, Ruhr-Pott-Duell. Und jetzt hat man eben in der Winterpause mit Olsen von Renners FC, das ist ein Rechtsverteidiger-Verstärker, Kalle Marschall von West Ham per Leier als Mittelstürmer und Ragnemärk ist ein Linksverteidiger. Also auch da hat man relativ klar Positionen festgestellt, wo es eben nicht ging, weil gerade das Offensivspiel, das haben wir so ein bisschen zur Hinrunde, es war schon ein sehr eindimensionales Spiel, was Bochum eben hatte. Michi, ich fange mal kurz bei dir nochmal an. Klar, Bochum spielt weiterhin, glaube ich, nicht die Sterne vom Himmel und ist als Bundesliga-Abschleiger natürlich, hängt immer noch so ein bisschen seinen Erwartungen vielleicht hier und da hinterher, aber per se muss man sagen, es ist schon beachtlich, was Uwe Rösler da beim VfL geschafft hat.
Ja, es ist vor allem beachtlich, wenn man denn die Zeit vor Uwe Rösler gesehen hat, wenn man auch gesehen hat, was er danach gemacht hat. Er hat erst mal sehr oft die Jugend gesetzt. Das war auch ein sehr mutiger Schritt. Jetzt ist er gar nicht mehr so jugendgeprägt, wie man sich die Startelf im Wochenende angeschaut hat. Also er hat vielleicht auch wieder ein bisschen auf Stabilität gesetzt, weil die Jugend das vielleicht auch nicht über 20, 25 Spiele in Folge leisten kann. Aber natürlich haben sie auch in der Rückrunde jetzt gegen fast nur Spitzen-Teams gespielt. Also wenn man sich jetzt mal anschaut, sie haben am 18. Spieltag Darmstadt 3-3, Elbersberg 1-1, Schalke gewonnen. Und jetzt kann jetzt Preußen Münster dann kein Spitzen-Team mehr, nur 1 zu 1. Das kommt auch dazu. Andererseits hat Uwe Rösler nach diesem Spiel gegen Preußen Münster jetzt dann auch gesagt, dass es Mitte gegen den Ball die beste Aussatzleistung seit ich hier bin, Zitat, war. Und man habe unheimlichen Mut bewiesen. Und es sei eigentlich eine Sensation, dass man mehr Ballbesitz als Preußen Münster habe. Und er hat vorhin Expected Goals über 2 gesprochen. Es waren dann 1,83. Also je nach Modell wahrscheinlich hat er wieder das DFL-Modell gesehen, das wieder deutlich höher liegt, warum auch immer. Aber 15 Schüsse, 7 Torschüsse, also das ist alles sehr stabil. Das hat halt nicht zum Sieg gereicht, aber davor hat man umgeschlagen gegen die Spitzenmannschaften der Liga. Insofern nach allem, was am Anfang war, ist das vollkommen okay. Und wenn man weiß, wie schwer es Mannschaften erwischen kann, nach einem Jahr in der Bundesliga, das sieht man gerade auch bei Heustern Kiel, dann ist der Vorfeld Buchum da gerade auf einem guten Weg, eine solide Übergangs-Saison zu spielen. Natürlich wird irgendwann das Ziel auch wieder mehr sein, aber in dieser Saison ging es darum, erst mal diesen Worst-Case zu vermeiden, der am Anfang ja drohte. Und jetzt ist man da wirklich einfach weit und auf einem guten Weg. Wenn der Trainer jetzt zufrieden ist mit der Entwicklung seiner Mannschaft, nimmt er auch mal ein 1-1 wahrscheinlich mit. Und dann werden sie vermutlich da unten auch nicht mehr reinrutschen. Weil es ja einfach auch, das habe ich schon mal gesagt, zu gut sind im Vergleich zu den Mannschaften, die da unten mitspielen.
Ja, finde ich ein guter Punkt. Ich fand ganz gut, dass, wenn ich mich jetzt auch nicht komplett täusche, man eben zwar eine Laie eben auch geholt hat eben im Winter, aber jetzt auch endlich mal, ich sage mal, Verpflichtungen, die über eine Halbserie hinausgehen. Das war ja so ein bisschen der Kritikpunkt, den man, den glaube ich auch Fans eben hatten, dass es so Ticken zu viel Laispieler vielleicht sind, wo du halt eben nicht weißt, okay, es ist ja alles schön und gut, dass wir uns sortieren sollen und junge Spieler und dies, das. Aber was bringt uns das, wenn im Sommer zu 50 Prozent alle wieder weg sind, so ungefähr, das muss man ja auch sagen, dann einfach Ruhbrecht und Co. Das ist ja auch immer die Frage, klar, mit Karlem Marschall hast du eben genau einen Spieler, der eben per Laie kommt, aber eben Olsen hat man eben von den Renders Mitablöse geholt und gerade davon nicht. Also seinem ersten Spiel in Münster, der hat schon gezeigt, was er da... Ich glaube, es ist eine sehr gute Idee, dass man das auf der rechten Seite bringen kann, muss ich sagen. Der hat dann nochmal neue Tiefe angeboten, einfach über die Außen. Und klar, ihr habt es eben schon angesprochen, Marschall eben, ja, nichts gegen Philipp Hoffmann, aber das war eben, da lag vielleicht auch, also erstens natürlich, ihr habt das angesprochen, die Jugendspieler, auf die man viel, ja, Last vielleicht auch sogar abgewälzt hat. Und dann halt irgendwie eben Philipp Hoffmann, der den natürlich auch immer wieder deine Tore macht, aber vielleicht jetzt auch nicht für immer die Lösung ist. Also da muss ich sagen, bietet Karl Marschall, ich finde, der ist jetzt auch nicht so der klassischste Mittelstürmer, wie gesagt, sondern der bringt echt, echt gut was mit. Das macht schon Spaß, dem da irgendwie vorne auch zuzusehen. Und das ist, glaube ich, genau das, was Bochum vorne einfach als kreativer Punkt eben auch gefehlt hat und was eben Fans auch, also ich weiß, da waren auch Leute gerade nach unserem Hinrundenrückblick auch anderer Meinung, aber das, was ich so eben von Bochum an eben auch gelesen habe, auch im 1848-Block war schon, dass Karl Marshall eben jetzt das mitbringt, was man vorher nicht hatte. Trotzdem muss man eben sagen, dieses Spiel gegen Münster, das musst du eigentlich verlieren, weil ich habe es eben schon mal gesagt, kein Team ist gerade so formschwach wie der SCP. Da war was drin und eigentlich ist es schon komplett unnötig, dass du in dieser Partie viel zu hoch stehst und dann kassierst du dieses 1-0. Also da steht die letzte Abwehrreihe von Bochum enorm hoch. Und wenn du halt sagst, wir nehmen mehr Ball als Münster, dann musst du dich halt darauf einstellen, dass Münster auf Konter geht. Und dann so offen zu stehen, ist natürlich nicht das Beste. Aber per se kann man glaube ich sagen.
War aber ein schöner Pass für Jotendrix, dem Ex-Fortuna und dem Geburtstagskind.
Ja, es war ein wunderschöner Pass. Also hat auf beiden Seiten natürlich Probleme auch offenbart, ehrlich gesagt dieses Spiel. Aber ich sehe trotzdem, also ich habe einfach die Hoffnung, no Offens an Bochum, aber diese Spiele anzugucken, waren halt auch wirklich einfach nicht schön. So, also weder war das, ich war bei Bielefeld gegen Bochum im Stadion, das war nicht schön. Das haben sie am Ende durch individuelle Klasse gewonnen, weil sonst gerne das Spiel auch einfach, weil beide Mannschaften so furchtbar schlecht waren, auch einfach 0-0 ausgehen. Beim Spiel gegen Hannover wissen sie selber nicht, wie die nicht verloren haben. Und jetzt hast du aber klar die ganzen Unentschieden. Es ist aber trotzdem, du verlierst halt nicht. So und das ist eben der positive Punkt. Du verlierst wenigstens keine Punkte nach unten, weil du Spiele verlierst. Das klingt total bescheuert und total simpel. Aber es ist gerade das, was dich eben einfach am Leben erhält und dich aus dieser direkten, direkten, wohlgemerkt Abschiedsgefahr raushält. Weil es also 27 Punkte, wir haben eben gesagt, so ganz wissen wir nicht, wo wir den Cut ansetzen können. Aber das ist schon mal eine gute Entwicklung. Thorsten, gerne.
Ja, ich wollte noch kurz was sagen und zwar, also zum einen, es war tatsächlich auch nur eine Niederlage unter Uwe Rösler. Und das ist natürlich wirklich der Wendepunkt der Saison. Ich war hier beim letzten Spiel sozusagen vor Uwe Rösler im Stadion. Das war die vorletzte Partie von Daniel Thun, hat man vielleicht mitgekriegt, war ein großes Endspiel etc. Und da lag wirklich ein großer Mehltau über dem ganzen VfL Bochum in der Zeit. Und ja, der wurde so ein bisschen durch Uwe Rösler weggepustet. Da war glaube ich dieses erste Spiel von ihm gegen Hertha, das war ganz, ganz wichtig. 3 zu 2 Sieg. Und ich glaube, dann sind ihm halt alle gefolgt. Kann man jetzt sehen, wie man will von– ich nenne es jetzt mal den Spökes, den er da vor den Fans immer macht mit kurzer Hose und so. Das sind manchmal vielleicht auch nette Geschichten. Für mich ist immer ein bisschen drüber, aber sei es drum. Ich kann aus der Erfahrung– Uwe Rösler war ja auch ein Düsseldorftrainer– kann ich sagen, ich habe immer das Gefühl gehabt, dass das eine Art ist, die sich relativ schnell verbraucht. Ich will es jetzt aber gar nicht zu sehr negativ für die Bochum-Fans sehen. Was damals wirklich ein großer Punkt war, als er nach Funkel kam, es schien wie eine taktische Revolution. Bei allem Respekt vor Friedhelm Funkel, aber er ist natürlich jetzt eher jemand, der über die Köpfe der Spieler kommt. Und da hat dann Rösler gerade, was das betrifft, einige Dinge eingeführt. Ich habe aber nicht das Gefühl, dass er bei Bochum so radikal Dinge verändert hat, sondern dass er tatsächlich die Köpfe der Spieler so ein bisschen da gut frei bekommen hat. Und ja, du hast schon über die Transfers gesprochen. Ich wollte noch einen billigen Witz machen, und zwar der Marschallplan hilft beim Wiederaufbau, ja. Das ist für die Geschichtsfreude hier. Und ich wollte aber noch eine Ergänzung machen. Also man hat natürlich auch vor allem Oliver Olsen geholt, als Ersatz für Felix Paszlak, der nämlich jetzt gegangen ist, zur Hibernian FC, sodass man da die Außenverteidigung so ein bisschen besser besetzen musste. Und ich wollte natürlich noch aus alter Verbundenheit Marcel Sobotka erwähnen, der als vereinsloser Spieler hat keinen neuen Vertrag letzten Sommer in Düsseldorf bekommen, jetzt beim VfL Bochum unter Vertrag ist. Und man kennt sich natürlich auch aus den Düsseldorfer Zeiten, sodass er da, ja ich sag mal als ein routinierter, jetzt nicht als Stammspieler, ist er bisher nicht, sondern eher so als ein routinierter Kaderspieler mit reingenommen wurde und da Masel Sobotka wirklich viele Freunde in Düsseldorf hat. Liebe Curissa an dieser Stelle. Wird ein bisschen schwer, wenn er auf dem Platz stehen dürfte. Er ist halt wirklich ein Spieler, der hier 10 Jahre gespielt hat. Das ist dann nicht schön, wenn Bochum Ende des Monats in drei Wochen dann zu uns kommt, sollte Masel Sobotka da im blauen Trikot sein. Das fühlt sich ein bisschen falscher.
Ja, das kann ich nachvollziehen. Ich würde sonst sagen, die nächsten beiden Spiele von VfW Bochum, das sind zwei Heimspiele. Und zwar gegen den SC Paderborn und den 1. FC Nürnberg. Also ja, auch eigentlich ganz spannend, weil ich glaube, also über Nürnberg haben wir heute gar nicht gesprochen, aber da auch, also im direkten Sinne, sage ich mal, auch da durchaus ja Potenzial da viel zu bereden beim 1. FCN. Auch was so, ja, Weggang von großen Persönlichkeiten betrifft, könnte man sagen. Sonst würde ich aber sagen, wir haben es nach, ich kann ja mal transparent sein, vorm Schlusswort wirklich, als hätte uns jemand da wirklich noch alles in die Wege geworfen. Von daher wundert euch nicht, wenn es hier auch etwas abgehackt ist im Schnitt hinterher. Wir haben es versucht, so best wie möglich zu lösen. Vielen, vielen Dank an der Stelle an Michi und Thorsten für euer Durchhaltevermögen, eure Geduld hier erst mal, das schon mal zu bewilligen generell. Und sonst kann ich sagen, ich würde sagen, bevor hier die Technik uns noch einen Strich durch die Rechnung macht, ich bin heute einfach mal richtig stumpf. Und sage an der Stelle vielen, vielen Dank an Michi Fischer für das kurzfristige Einspringen. Es ist immer wieder eine Freude mit dir. Danke, Michi.
Sehr gerne. Geduld und Durchhaltevermögen sind wichtige Attribute als Reporter bei der Spielverhandlung aus Fürth. Danke.
Und dann lieben Dank auch an Thorsten für dein Debüt hier.
Ja, vielen, lieben Dank für die Einladung. Das hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Und dann sehen wir uns in zwei Wochen wieder. Macht's gut. Tschüss. Tschüss. Das war der Rasenfunk.
Von Ihnen unterstützt.
Herzlichen Dank. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.